[Musique]
mais venus à sans fil le podcast on
parle lorsqu'on avec nos invités dati
site super quand avec moins de plantes
cette semaine le sans fil est encore une
fois présenté par la gagne des terriers
terriens qui sont les héros des potières
malades terrain dernier c'est un bureau
de comptable ça fait 25 ans qui existent
ils sont au service des petites et
moyennes entreprises de 1 à 100 employés
qui oeuvrent dans les domaines d'avenir
donc ici on parle créateur web jeux
vidéo pharmaceutiques biotechnologiques
et autres domaines connexes
on s'entend ça fait des domaines assez
futuriste si on veut dont ils ont
développé une expertise pour ces
choses-là ailleurs offre un service clé
en main aux entrepreneurs comme ça comme
des jeunes entrepreneurs comme deux
mémoires ce moment qui se lance dans un
projet comme ça on se fait chier un peu
avec la la fiscalité la patente de
garder nos comptes et toupie sûr que les
gens qui vont en affaires c'est pas pour
faire de la paperasse et pas pour faire
la comptabilité
c'est vraiment pour innover et terrain
terriens vous permettre de faire ça il
vous offre un service clé en main comme
jeu de salaire avec votre tenue de
livres avec vos états financiers avec
vos rapports d'impôt demande de crédit
d'impôt multimédia existera donc c'est
vraiment un service 3,60 pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs qui veulent pas se casser
la tête
et en plus on vous offre un code promo
en mentionnant sans filtre lorsque vous
allez prendre votre rendez vous chez
terrain terrain ils vont vous donner 50
% pour votre première année financière
ce qui est très considérable mais tant
est que vous voulez mettre votre argent
et votre énergie dans votre entreprise
et non dans la comptabilité donc allé
voir ce sur un terrien trait d'union cpa
point com qui est leur site web pour
avoir plus d'informations sinon sinon
cette semaine au podcast
georges laraque georges laraque premier
premier ex joueur des canadiens premier
joueur la lnh qu'on soit au podcast
comment mieux
commencer qu'avec georges laraque un kit
joué treize ans avec d'actionnaires qui
tend un gars avec un parcours quand même
ses hôtes du chaos du communiqué qu'ils
étaient on a parlé un petit peu de
justement comment qui a réussi à
atteindre son rêve de jouer au hockey de
jouer dans les nationales quand tout le
monde se donne lui lui en décourage été
comme étant un peu seul noir dans sa
gangue avec on a parlé beaucoup de sport
ça a été un petit con à profiter
justement de parler de sport qu'on a
parlé un petit peu moins souvent en ph
kit un kit un plus vous vraiment plus
grand que dans l'histoire de ce sport
professionnel et sport vraiment plus que
moi puis georges laraque aussi jour là
qui à chaque jour en émission à radio
il parle de sport fait qu'on a vraiment
connecté là dessus sinon ben un autre
notion sur laquelle on connecte c'est
surtout ph encore une fois ci le
véganisme georges laraque qui du jour au
lendemain en regardant un documentaire
des comptes à terrier devenu vegas ça
fait 2010 2011 - c'est ça dans ce
coin-là pas ce qui est dit aujourd'hui
restera vegan il sera impliqué plusieurs
compagnies heidsieck et médiatique et
vegan donc on a parlé de ce type à
belles rencontres et aussi on parle de
violence au hockey comme philosophie
autour de ce spa vos podcasts qu'une
personne qui les tickets qui payent qui
se passe en premier barbecue doit parler
dans un micro
safari 5 est espace pas intéressant puis
belle rencontre beaucoup de casse ouais
exact une excellent discussions avec un
grand homme un grand si vous aimez ce
qu'on fait là maintenant on est à
nouveau studio on a plein de nouveaux
projets qui s'en viennent fait que la
meilleure façon de rester à l'affût de
tu sais vous abonner à notre chaîne que
ce soit sur l'application baradeau sur
sport des failles sur youtube commenté
fait partie de l'adduction fait partie
et du de notre communauté
sans fil podcast est une façon comme
meilleur de faire partie de la
communauté c'est d'aller voir notre page
pétrone les infos one hand et sur la
vidéo
donc encore une fois merci à terrain
terrain de nous permettre de faire ça
merci à georges pour son temps et on
vous souhaite un bon par cast bonne
écoute
[Musique]
et c'est commencer merci d'arrêter
l'accident sont des gars liliane les
deux en plus avec ian thorpe et toute
chose combien 13 jan toi qui choisis
quoi ouais comme acquise et à tout cas
il y était et devait mesurer s'il a
grandi mais c'est vraiment c'était comme
la fasti qu'acheter incognito second top
ten les jambes à cause de la taille de
ses pieds qui foulaient le voyait
maintenant sur le blog de des portes qui
mettait les pieds de ses deux pieds
faisait le bloc au complet si tu y es tu
meilleur américain où la marque paco
faire cohabiter le avant une fois un
contre l'autre c'était à athènes en 2004
puis ian thorpe avait gagné le 200 kral
puis faire juste arrivé troisième mais
l'année d'après faire de battre le
record du monde 2h15 le service des
costumes à cause des costumes sont aussi
l'état plus rapide
et comme illégal parce que t'es trop
lisse
dans le fond les les appeler seul et les
maillots de performance les listes et
des ae nec fait qu'ils montaient
jusqu'ici
puis en 2009 une compagnie en fait sont
arrivés en 2008 mais en 2009 c'est là
que c'est devenu problématique une
commune qui s'appelait jay kay est en
fait un maillot que de 100% en
polyuréthane
puis ça ça faisait que premièrement sa
gaine fx acer est tellement fort que tu
attends un gars comme toi qui est ultra
fort mais qui est lourd ce ça faisait
que ça permettait d'abord comme si je
faisais des abdos à chaque jour sa en
forme et on le fait que ça te remonter
sur l'obs ça faisait que les gros gars
qui était vraiment fort c'était comme si
leur brosse et des rames fait que ça
favoriser ce qui était moins en forme
plus fort - fit mettons ce en 2009 tout
les records du monde sont fait battre
les lions ont retiré ses maillots de
bain mais les recrutements sont d'accord
avec ça mais en fait il y en a seulement
deux ou trois autres qui ont pas été
rebattues après parce qu'ils y ont
changé la règle pile à la règle était
devenu en mode nombre et en os des
genoux fallait que ce soit 100% dans un
matériau durable puis c'est quoi le
métal plus le droit de polluer autant
ces événements sion non non non jamais
une mention sauf qu'ils ont été battus
en a comme deux ou trois qui sont encore
là puis sur une question de temps mais
mais justement il y en avoir plus est un
des premiers qui mangeait avec un
maillot de bain qui allait jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au poignet jusqu'aux chevilles
weyts bas du dos ouais mais maintenant
on n'est autre que je pense pas qu'on
allait commencer en parlant de notation
je m'attendais flatteur les torpilles
vécu je m'attache à tes jambes mais doit
avoir quand même une bonne explosivité
mais dans l'autre pour la vie en général
mais j'ai fait de la crise quand j'étais
jeune j'ai beaucoup je courais beaucoup
tes je faisais des sprints l'homme en
est c'est quand tu es quand tu es jeune
c'est une chose mais quand je commence à
joie qui agit là du 15-16 ans berthe et
coach des rendus à 230 240 ha ouais bébé
c'est un format plus tard sur le corps
du rock tout le monde sait ça pue massa
m'a fait beaucoup demain soir était très
bonne mais les plaquettes si je faisais
juste pour les guerres d'ex pousse les
cloisons qu'anticipait deux camps ceux
de la plus longue et rit quand tu vois
ses thèmes importants les blocs de
départ mais vous devez jeter tous été
jeunes cela changer énormément mais
socke est il pour les départs leurs
systèmes importants les choix qu'on a
exercé sur les choix qu'on fait
aujourd'hui avec des blocs de départ ce
que même ben johnson grand train de
piquer souvent ne possédez pas un hobby
qui pâtissent pas d'aimer ben à lui
facilement pour les traits de
l'explosion un exactement donc s'occuper
seuls important mais à la nage
malheureusement ça m'a jamais des mêmes
crache pas plus jeunes pourraient vous
êtes chanceux parce que j'ai toujours
rêvé de faire un homme qui à un moment
donné j'ai fait ce besoin d'énormément
tout comme le marathon
si le format exactement un demi marathon
à l'image de celui je n'oublierai jamais
ce que j'ai fait explique l'istat 800
d'un ange - 42 vélo ils disent de course
le 800m nage je mens sieste en même
temps puisque la qualification aux
algues peuvent pour le monde puisqu'elle
est aux olympiques
il bute joie qui évoluent dans ce
temps-là primes ont donné une chance non
excusez moi c'est un point 16 km de
natation d'un ange de natation 40 de
vélo pittis de cours fixé à 1500 le
monde et se qualifie pour les jeux
olympiques mais vu jouer à keolis me
laisser embarquer dans laquelle les jags
dans les jambes que leurs créations
quinze minutes du match ne fait que
j'arrive à la marge
il ya plein de monde qui regarde c'est
un impulsif il mail moi j'arrive avec
mes choix mais moi ça me regarde le
théâtre nantis sont intenses c'est à
dire demain moustache york le
département le moins coté que j'ai couru
oublie seul et l'annoncé des machines à
des gars qui étaient des tares pays
parte elle a dans ce sens avant je
voyais plus personne un témoin gênant
spylo c'est un peu sale un peu l'eau est
un peu noir de ce cammas est fatigués la
présidente est dès lors c'est parce que
ces 800 mhz et on sort de l'eau monte en
puissance après le pays
pendant que j'étais à peu près à la
moitié du 400 il arrivait déjà pour
faire deuxième tome mais c'était sur le
dos encore clos l arrivée dans ma face
c'est des gars là c'est que justement
gratter choisi dans l'eau pendant 47
minutes
mais j'avais fini mais je tends seul
après les autres comme ceux des dix
quinze minutes c'est fini les deux mots
cachés cnis prometteuse sortie donc
fallu y a plus personne
l'idée déjà rage sur le vélo le ch est
le seul lucky aussi ferme après - vélo
pourquoi courir à l'attention des
personnes noires
jamas vélo stepper personnes c'est un
des plus plaque progressé de la présente
saison
c'est pour ça qu'elle fit plus à l'inter
mais je n'ai jamais dit ça c'est la comm
cre assez nombreux au monde ego un feu
d'abord la natation c'est là bas nos de
beaucoup de triathlètes qui commence
souvent ce sont des gens qui ont les
background de course de vélo pitié pour
pour denner gens comme nous la distance
de natation par rapport au reste du
monde ici c'est ridicule c'est
maintenant mais tend à remettre aux 4
kilomètres de 0.9 point 9 séries 182
vélo 42 courses 3.9 de notation pour des
nageurs c'est comme si rien par rapport
au reste
mais pour quelqu'un qui est prêt qui
rendit en argent c'est un bond de 2 pc
quand je mange le c'est mon corps et mes
jambes sont tout le temps et ça les
garder loin en vacances non je force
moi mon du corps parce que je cale
tellement pas si mes jambes sont pas
droites zoo ses droits ça vous faites
sont capables du monde qui m'ont aidé
conduit mon bassin ont tous fait
puissions aborder serov le thé du monde
musculaire en natation c'est souvent un
port les gens qui performent plus c'est
du monde vraiment musculation et
maintenant il faudrait que ce soit de 50
puis s'arrête là parce que sinon c'est
plus de plus tu étais tu est lourd plus
calme l'utica le site off d'autres
corvées à surface faisant le calcul est
simple est dopé c'est que moi je voulais
pas compétitionné je vais juste faire un
armement est capable de faire 1 4 kg
100 canaux qui me chercher vos boussoles
je pense pas jamais être capable de
faire quatre kilomètres s'arrêter
maintenant plusieurs fois semaine ça
c'est plus latin c'est l'énergie oui
mais j'étais malgré tout les gens qui
n'ont je peux je sais comment accepter
enfin - alors essayez c'est la course
même si je pourrai plus vite je peux
faire n'importe quoi en vélo sur faire
n'importe quoi mais si vous vous en vous
êtes là quatre 4 mois c'est la fin du
monde
j'aime bien mieux face à 80 km de vélo à
la main km de vélo de messi des rêves
c'est tellement technique de natation de
cépie ça s'apprend sur longtemps qui
doutent de la mort fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme un peu en
critique maintenant pas nagé pendant 20
heures puis allez dans peace and en vain
tant pis j'aurais une technique pas pire
c'est sauve qui comme et reste comme une
langue sens la brancher sa tête vous
surprendre mais quand j'étais jeune à
sorel tracy faisait partie d'un club de
natation a encore des records à la barre
les notations crédit très jeune quand
j'avais espace saint louis qui ravira
tous les jours là tous les joueurs de
passer un club si moi-même atrassi tu
peux aller voir de la drass comme celle
de je me suis dit quand j'aurai à
prendre ça j'allais peut-être sa larve
mais moi j'aime c'est la fin du mois les
triathlons piles et r'n'b soul et r'n'b
ces méthodes pour moi il ya deux
vraiment deux catégories lille ce qu'ils
font pour gagner les pros bien ce qu'ils
font pour le frob dans les deux cas
c'est honorable mais les athlètes qui
compétitionne pro sur le circuit de la
coupe du monde de harry même p-dg mis à
l'honneur
c'est parmi les personnes qui
m'impressionne le plus beau que tu
fasses t'es foutu passe tellement de
temps à courir à faire du vélo pis pour
de sordides avec les gens fait de la
natation fait faut que tu t'entraînes
aussi en natation si j'allais c'est du
nord qui sont
bon ben c'est pas de la partie d'un
bruce schneier qui sont bons même par
rapport à des nageurs l'étude puisque
des précédents c'est que c'était pas le
meilleur ou un des meilleurs l'argent
qui concerne les acteurs de points c'est
vraiment pour la passion le jeu monster
pour survivre aux faces que tu aimes
alors apparaître très grands vins europe
qui peut-être tonka tessala de rien mais
moi je reconnais que ce qu'ils font
c'est incroyable mais ces gens-là les
plus tard leurs cordes comme étant un
maillon travail et comment il y en a
plein d handicap
commentitte accroupi dans ton vélo
pendant longtemps comme ça puis quand
même chose c'est une articulation les
genoux pour la course où sea lounge pour
ce qu'eux mêmes aujourd'hui cela qui est
pas mal plus de vélo parce que la course
mes genoux agcc enfin livre quoi s est
ce que l'on fait pour les deux fois je
vais devoir de montréal à la ligne
d'arrivée ou de départ le monde me
regardait la scène extérieure fait le
marathon de la cua tomber les pm ça
j'aime sans avoir mal souffraient tous
les gens autour de moi c'est quelque
chose à ça mais j'ai fait pareil si
j'avais fait deux fois puis je m'en
foutais de daphné j'aime pas fini
derrière +4 à 59
c'est sous la selle des minéraux qui
permet à la marine
je mentionne avant la fois les flics je
prenne six lettres d'électrolytes de
l'hôpital de limoges 18 ans je te mords
de déshydratation parce que au 32e
kilomètre des bosses dans tout le corps
de déshydratation vous avez des bonnes à
l'écran mais ça fait des bosses dans ton
coin on attendra encore il boitait le
marché en boîte un si je restais justice
clame en exigeant que j'ai 32 ans je
savais que j'avais des crampes je peux
pas arrêter résiste que le rythme et
c'est comment c'était dangereux
c'est conduisent pas à chaud il y en a
six qui m'a fait arrêter avec ça c'est
quoi
j j allais me suis dit si je mens au
moins j'ai avoir au moins essayer
surtout tellement j'ai vraiment trouvé
sa connaissance vous se réveiller mais
j'avais les deux brutalité staff ou
noircir les médecins m'avaient parlé
plus nazi n'a pas le poids
au fait je m'en suis rendu compte que je
suis un peu car il m'a dit je prendrai
plus de décès fausses prend plein de
choses l'année d'après j'ai décidé de la
faire un cross puis j'ai fait en une
heure de plus parce qu'après 21 clamer
je me suis blessé
les boîtes up les gens d'affaires en
boîte un bon moi j'ai un pas deux camps
mais là si je marchais ce marché un
marché pratiquement fait que ce matin
c'est quand même comique passe mes amis
du monde était inquiet de l'arrivée
quelque chose près le deuxième j'ai
arrêté je pense que ton compte envoyer
des messages
parce que les demi j'ai fait en une en
54 mais les fins jacobs toujours
arrangements jeudi m j'ai fait le
marathon de québec l'année passée de
foule ouais ouais ouais je fais j'ai
fait trois ans et en 3h37 ouais mais
mais la force et le jeu viennent faire
le demi-marathon de lévis la semaine
passée j'ai fait une heure trente
fake culte est une machine bah j'ai même
pensé que mon chat encourus j'ai couru
vraiment beaucoup sauf que au marathon
le fait d 21 kg d'entraînement de mai il
rien qui prépare à quand tu arrives à 30
kg oui y'a rien qui préparera seul parce
qu'il faut octant forec hawks face des
35 en entraînement tous les instruments
tu arrives là le puits parce que le demi
marathon j'ai fait des 21 en fait je le
fais pis c'est moins long qu'un
entraînement et un an et demi des fois
je coure deux heures sauf que le
marathon comme tel il ya vraiment un
lieu où s est encore jamais allé heureux
c'est qu'un pote il lassé du territoire
nouveau j'ai les deux jambes qui craque
complètement j'ai envie de marcher j'ai
envie d'appeler ma mère disait venir me
chercher c'est et tire vraiment un gap
c'est de la voir comment tu vois ça ma
foi que je pensais que toi je pense que
j'ai fait à bressan de l'humarathon que
je peux faire un marathon pas besoin de
faire un placement
j'avais plein de 21 à lot c'est le dos 1
mais tu as raison c'est pas deux fois à
30 km en avoir des trains je n'ai jamais
fait exact faudrait faire des trucs sans
se préparer pour cela basket en corse
n'ont aucune des îles en qu'elles ont
quittée après le premier quand j'ai vu
quand même car en défaisant manche et là
oublient ça je fais pas des 35
c'est sympathique marathon surface qui
me brûlait c'est vrai ça devienne normal
que ce soit pas trop tough pas trop
longs mentalement et on est que plus tu
en as fait plus ça passe vite
c'est ce que j'ai trouvé dans plus court
des kilomètres et des kilomètres
là maintenant un 10 km pour moi
maintenant ça passe de même si mini
sortie challenge fait 10 km je reviens
pas nécessairement l'impression d'avoir
couru comme falaise kulczyk la force
mentale que ça prendrait tant
déshydratation potasse et fournit des
cloches pendant que put it in a love que
je le finisse a pâti ces longs 10 kg en
marche et le way je veux tu quatre jours
et nationale 1 puis que tu t'es battu tu
ta carrière
puis quand date est d'attaquants du
monde qu'ils pouvaient tuer le jeu des
guides et a pas qu'eux
tu vis quand jacques ex bp oiseaux et
puis pas de grand chose après exacte et
même si ch avec flamme horaires et à
chaque combat je peux mourir au moins
avait rien le pipa jeu ça y est les
goûts aussi n'ai-je pas pas de l'égo de
fenay mes premiers jeux ça les japonais
un premier les bouddhas légaux d'abord
donné le nain qui regarde tu encourages
le monde me regardait tpiy moi je me
sens nettement 10 des parts qu'ils aient
ce qu est ce que cela puisse être
je ne peux pas abandonner et si
j'abandonne montrent que je t'adore h le
même si ça faisait mal et que c'est pour
ça fait moi c'était pas mal
si je faisais les goûts m'a énormément
parce que tu es si tu commences quelques
chauffe-eau souverainiste je regarde
c'est des exemples de courage de
personnes qui l'ont fait qu'ils ont il y
en a qui on fusille on finira en page 6
ap lundi soir comme attendu des
unijambistes ou des personnes vraiment
âgées ou des choses se sont passées là
dans des histoires d'enfants chaque
année que mouchetés comme à cause de
crampes
même si seulement j'avais arrêté ses
jantes à 30,2 pour annie maintenant ma
tête j'en faisais pas un autre lapresle
c'était le dernier c'était le seul de ma
vie surtout comment ça avait fait moi je
me sors je pense à travers ces jachères
c'est la même c'est la plus grosse
douleur de toute ma vie
moyennant quelques points l'enfer tout
l'écho citic robben toutes les combines
mercenac robin ensemble ils te chnique
projet mangera un cool ça ferait moins
mal que le plus que les 10 km est gênant
pour et avec des crampes là c'est la
paire à fond mais c'est qu'il ya une
semaine après ce épreuve sa loterie 100
cuir - demi de marché comme ils fois
noah malade c'est que la puissance du
bain la puissance mentale qui soit mais
la puissance de se comparer à des
situations qui sont son pays et que la
note c'est quand tu vis quelque chose
comme sujet précis des miennes les leurs
de détruire des jets de portland dans la
nba lui ai demandé toute la pression
sinon la pression mesure un jeu la
pression c'est la mère monoparentale qui
sait pas s'il y avait amené de la bourse
à table c'est le telle personne qui
grandit dans un quartier
vraiment pauvre qui veut sortir de là ça
c'est de la pression quotidien moi je
paye des millions $ bourg pour jour ce
qui est urgence et à me plaindre la
pression s'est étendue quand tu compare
à ce qui est comme tu dis du monde
qu'ils font à une jambe du monde qui
fondent et qui traverse le canado
complet en chaise roulante avec b les
ampoules des mains est un gars qui a
fait le tour des la grande bretagne en
auge les affaires de malade mental tu
fais ok 10 km de course ça valait que tu
m'aimes pour moi je veux plus loin sa
une et parents sont en haïti
il était deux fois quand j'étais jeune
qui veut dire en haïti le let's get ur
garde la douleur que les enfants passent
à travers comment les enfants crèvent de
faim je regarde juste la tragédie qui
est arrivé en haïti
mes parents seraient à ses labos
pétremand aujourd'hui fait que bouger
notre réalité par dessus la douleur qu
est aujourd'hui le traitement en haïti
où il est proche pour est et j'aurais
jamais la vie que j'ai aujourd'hui
chiffres estimés par an serait restée là
bas et c'est pour ça que en tant qu est
des migrants qu'un petit ici puisque
heavy rain personal tout un sport que
l'on parle de douleurs de choses où j'ai
vu des choses quand je t elle enfin
quand j'attendais éthique urbain les
enfants québec qui pourrait pourrait
jouer de toute une équipe une éducation
ci pourra voir ces choses là toujours
aux soins surtout on est dégoûtés on
shore surtout moelleux quand j'ai vu des
choses que j'ai vu quand j'étais jeune
je pense que prenait ducation d'un
parent ou les dames et ceux des enfants
world business et emmène dans la vie
voir la vraie pauvreté comment les vrais
thélème la planète et la pauvreté d'une
grande partie de la planète quand même
vraiment vu quand les enfants sont
capables d'avoir ce puits de plus
d'après si dans quoi et vivent ou les
violer ma chambre mais pas assez belle
j'ai passé des tas de matériel le tir et
alice qu'était vraiment chanceux lice
pour ça que ses voyages le moins d
beaucoup à réaliser que c'est la chance
que j'avais aujourd'hui encore plus que
jamais eq cette ode à chialer sur son
sort quand quand tu réalises que les
millions de personnes qui changerait
places avec toit vraiment si on avait le
comparatif souvent en vacances je te
demande pas ce qu'on
on n'a pas la comparaison la portée de
la main et sion vois pas à quel point
cette situation et via le web c'est quoi
la s'est comparé à ce que les gens font
en plus ça c'est un gros problème c'est
que au lieu de ce conte est choyé à
comparer avec des gens qui sont moins
fortunés mais moins fortunés que nous
que ce que les gens se comprend avec des
gens on est jaloux avec les gens tout se
regarder quelqu'un qui dans le même
temps que toi qui plus que plus de
succès tu faisais je préfère manger que
lui plaît le mensonge a loupé le sont en
terrain négatif des pensées négatives et
avance au lieu d'être contre la personne
qui font ce qu'ils réussissent dans la
vie les gens dont la négativité parce
que ils sont frustrés mais quand tu es
frustré peu pour rien à voir ce danger
parce que l'énergie négative n'est pas
avancer denrées et souvent c'est ça même
trajet coûte des conversations plus
quand je fais des conférences conférence
et sur des conférences de motivation
le problème c'est sa fille venant des
business put attend des gens parler lors
du dîner les gens qui parlent à la pause
ils font juste et chez le chiot les sur
leur sort soit sort des autres sur telle
ou telle personne au lieu d'avancer peut
dépenser plus pour ce que tu en bout de
ligne le vase mentalement c'est pas
juste de croire en quelque chose mais
c'est de s'entourer d'énergie positive
pourquoi complet à ses seins choix qui
est pas mal de dire qu'il déchire lippi
tige
mais prendre un chocolat avant cela et
c'est un passé bien personne qui va
chialer dans tous demandé va compresser
râle parce que maman n'ait commencé peu
avant c'était entouré noir de négatif je
pense que la planète les comtois la vie
à ne jamais rien eu sur un plateau
d'argent trop parvenir
bon ok je veux sauf le tigre cette offre
met ton rêve est gros plus des obstacles
sont énormes et plus le la récompense
après elle est exceptionnelle quand ça
arrive c'est fx pour ce que sam
importante c'est de toujours avoir des
bonnes énergies pire donner le meilleur
de soi même
vraiment c'est vraiment si vraiment
important je pense de changer de
perspective par rapport à une situation
et arrive quelque chose qui prend la
perspective de de quelqu'un d'autre qui
qui qui oppose que toi tu
quelqu'un d'autre qui verrait ça comme
un challenge positif qui verrait ça
comme une façon de se dépasser une façon
d'améliorer ton propre sort avec cette
percée cette perspective là tout devient
une espèce de défi positif à accomplir
c'est un espèce de hacker moi je veux
faire ça mais il ya un problème d'un
guide régler le problème ça va être ça
va m'amener du bien ça me permet
d'atteindre quelque chose d'autre même
principe que quand tu quand tu
t'entraînes pilote urssaf en bétail
moutons
c'est ce jeudi à t'entraîner c'était pas
le fun sauf que tu prends plaisir à
savoir que tu as accompli quelque chose
qui est difficile pour atteindre le
meilleur objectif le but un fonds est la
chose la plus gratifiante dans le sport
je pense que c'est pour une raison qui
fait que le monde font du sport de ce
niveau là en parlais tantôt des
triathlètes qui font pas une seule
j'ai pour ce feeling là en grosse partie
ce feeling de réussir un meilleur temps
le feeling de dépasser physiquement le
feeling de d'atteindre un autre niveau 2
il écrit mais non même type moi ça
m'arrange je sais je donnerais jamais
jamais fait d'elle un premier apport son
funk et 10 avril et fin mai pour
récemment au quotidien ça me dépasse et
décida format tant que je faisais avant
c'est tout con toi même et je pige
loppsi foulée je vais la compétition
toute ma vie mais disent on s'entend je
n'ai jamais jamais je peux m'entraîner
pendant 100 ans j'ai jamais gagné une
course c'est ça mais c'est pas ça la
force et que l'autre jour comparé ce que
j'ai fait depuis c'est le fun devra le
prêt qu'ils ont fait en trois mois si
c'est pour toi tu es d'enfants comme ça
mais juste de faire de battre son propre
temps c'est toujours une petite victoire
chaque fois que tu es content de ça
c'est tout ce que ça principaux commence
par des clips collectif que vous donne
quelque chose mais pour ce que c'est
d'un côté de l'autre puisque tu dis là
dessus je comprend énormément parce -
raison pour laquelle je fais souvent
c'est juste pour me dépasser et essuie
maiden moi même de ma situation de ce
que parce que je vais à comprendre mais
je lisais jeudi son livre je n'ai pas
encore terminé mais je les nie peut-être
la moitié pis tu racontes dans le début
que quand été repêché par les oilers
ils ont présenté un jour de causes
préparateur physique je peux tropiques
il faisait faire des des challenge
physique et qui avait juste aucun
comment ça les gars illégaux y avait un
paquet à côté des vieux parce qu'il
vomissait petits continuez le gars
c't'un synchronise braqueurs beristain
c'est un très bon et très athlétique il
était quand même reconnus qui est à côté
il faisait faire des afad lui ils se
poussent à tellement qu'il vomit sa part
max entre un instant c'est incroyable je
n'oublierai jamais ce quart été repêché
par les 195 caterpillar ma main il
laisse trois tous les gars qu'on
aperçoit la face deuxièmement il fait
des avec les gâteaux des repêchés sont
des sorties d'albums
cette pointe et prenant durban est
hâtive québec à voir nos amis pis montre
le chandail noir qu'elle comptait rdpc
est une expérience qui l'a vu que
j'étais repêché en tant que les
blackberry
il était comme là pour voir mois que le
premier choix cynique et y aller pour
nous parler d'entraînement ce qu'on
devait au compte de vincent traîner tes
l'été pour arriver au camp
d'entraînement en forme
ouais j'ai dit c'est en revanche un
pilote et je le vois le plein
il nous est donné en short jean tichané
joue bien j'ai sonné on était dans le
bus la veille ouais quand même
quand on pense que tu es vous nous
montrez et mouvements à l'honneur des
choses parce que on n'avait pas de stock
maison on dans le tunnel où il y avait
tout seul at il dit je lui ai dit les
choses qui ont été les enductions girl's
douaniers ils nous ont gardé une semaine
de plus
on s'entraînait comme des maladies
mentales je la mort et moi je décore
mabrouk à mombasa regardez-moi pas le
premier choix pour ceux qui se confient
tout nos amis tard tourner au québec ou
en ontario ce qui sont repêchés pour ses
célèbres et ont été repêchés pseudo on
est enfin cours est tombé malade
s'entraîner par de chagny qu'on n'ait
jamais fait il s'agit en major si jamais
tu as comme seulement comme un tir
détourné cette journée de fou que nous
engueule toute la journée en fait sera
très mais cash sera venu dans l'avion la
coop mon cas j'ai mains partout puis
j'avais même plus que vous célébrez avec
d'abord été repêché tâche me disait
souvent cachés et merci pour ça je me
faisais quand je revenais ameute les
foules qui m'atteint taken by allez vous
casser un peu resté à quai les gêne ça
va être sérieux ligue nationale c'est
quand c'est un pauvre et oui parce que
depuis ce temps là j'ai toujours été un
d eux dans les trous dans les comptes
sont à chaque enfant moteur démarre à
cause qu'est ce qu'il ya comme c'est
d'abord quand on fait ce qu'il faut
je prenais un entraîneur privé puis je
me poussait à fond pour être un aimant à
condition chaque année
quelque chose des militaires les danois
les à camarès que est ce qu'il ya eu un
changement dans la façon avec laquelle
les gueux lasnier france en train dans
ce moment parce que moi j'écoutais
excuse moi j'écoute en pas de casque
appel spitting chiclet
ouais c'est paul missionnaire la barbie
puis aux hôtes y raconte des histoires
développe peut-être quinze ans dans les
nationales le ccc des gars qui sont un
peu sa brosse dans le vestiaire oui
comme dans les temps on est dans l'autre
truites pour une coupe de gameplay guèye
sorte après bis défense après un guet
mais on dirait que j'ai l'impression
maintenant moi je m'entraînais au peps
avec le gym du rouge et or il y avait
des gars qui s'entraînait créé mon
meilleur dégâts nationale antoine
vermette entre autres david desharnais
était le marc édouard vlasic s'entraîner
là puis moi je voyais une semaine après
s'être fait éliminer en série marc
édouard vlasic et l appui il s'entraîne
à tout les jours est ce que tu penses
qu'il ya comme un une tour nord qui ont
été prises ou c'était vraiment
l'histoire que j'entends par exemple ce
paquet c'est juste une minorité des gens
parce que aujourd'hui que sa mère a
tellement changé que c'est tellement
rendu rapide que celle des anciens
joueurs comme marc édouard vlasic qui
s'entraîne pas regardé une certaine
forme et rapidité
l'os faire de la déplacer parce que
c'est tellement axée sur la rapidité qu
alors qu'avant c'était pas comme ça
avant c'était beaucoup tu sais tu es
grosse tête à forte et c'est correct
puis les gangs s'entre et net c'est
beaucoup certainement statique
j'aime beaucoup le maintenant et
l'explosivité légués au fonds de la
voyons à mach menace est basée plus sur
l'entraînement qui était en mouvement
parce que si cela vraiment statique ton
musclé jeu statique
quand tu bouges ton post apo stabilité
de rien maintenant c'est la plus la
plomée trick qui équipe spécifique d'un
entraînement légaux bouge beaucoup plus
sélective aux différences la game est
plus rapide puis si aujourd'hui tu es
trop sur le porter mais malheureusement
ce qui se passe maintenant cycle avant
dans le temps quand les vétérans y avait
plus de place à tribord entraînements
les recruter dans cette courte et
maintenant suffisant la recrue
maintenant prend la place de 21
on a pu on ne put pas de trace
maintenant les vétérans de l'alignement
ya pas de statut non avec le plafond
salarial maintenant c'était un gars de
troisième quatrième trio puis une recrue
harry fait la job paraît comme toi pivot
coûté 500 millions
en place tout en maintenant ce qui
arrive là dedans c'est que les vétérans
le savent cette pression le cas donc ils
n'ont pas le choix de s'entraîner
vraiment pour vraiment être prêt pour
poster déloger jamais métier c'est ce
que le deportivo toujours en avoir
et la seule chose qui est un peu plate
aujourd'hui c'est quand dans le temps
les gars prennent un coup allez go
sortait maintenant ne plus avoir de
coquins moisséens la maintenance et les
pilules maintenant parce que les
rapports à la merveille le lendemain
notamment il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de codes soleil nationale en ce
moment en plein essor et say we impose
des règles contre les stéroïdes mais
veulent la faire aussi pour les suspects
et les vaisseaux les drogues etc la
cession des joies défend pour someval
seulement ça va arriver là si vous tuez
des footeux se protègent les joies de
moi et me vois pas ce que c'est comme
plus à l'avance c'est dans la société
d'aujourd'hui projets dans la soie
professionnels et les jeunes aujourd'hui
bora s'est plu à ses forces et chimiques
maintenant qui plus est malheureusement
on voit de plus en plus ce qui est très
désolant en espérant ne jamais voir une
personne sans souffrir à cinq ans
pitt et on oublie aussi quel point il ya
les jeunes là dedans le tri tout est
fini tu avais 17 ample avec une prime de
265 mille piastres d'un coup c'est comme
c'est beaucoup d'un coup comme pour
quelqu'un qui ait choisi ce cas que la
célébrité ça c'est facile de perdre la
carte c'est on parle plus de 65000 mes
pinceaux soit cohérente et 5 millions
comme soit végétale de 65000 car
tottenham forks et postons prochain
combat peut être ton dernier c'est pas
la même chose et pas ce petit
l'investiment tu le sais pas ce qui va
arriver
qui et puis même j'ai fait des conneries
quand j'ai commencé à jouer dépensé sur
des cochonnets des charges portent la
fois comme sonne mes potes même niveau
que certaines personnes qui faisaient
2,3 millions il fait perdre la carte
encore plus passer encore plus les
moyens il flashe encore plus mais c'est
pour ce que tu es c'est tellement
important de t d c'est important d'être
bien entouré et pis dans l'éducation
petit invite les gens qui sont autour de
toi parce que
cette sauvegarde ça arrive pas beaucoup
dans l'arc et parce que les joueurs sont
plus éduqués maintenant basket-ball
football
beaucoup d'athlètes ont des seins en toi
tu aimes entourage que et tu dois payer
pour les aider à vivre partout mais
quelqu'un ce matin très peu d'argent
mais ces sports le team et on en parlera
occupent des commandes les joueurs de
hockey les joueurs locaux et
professionnels sont pas poindre en
termes de rémunération l'été mais tu
compares c'est au basket le cd6 potier
mettons ok tu fais 10 millions par année
c'est un gros dossier les hauteurs de
basket c'est comme céder 50 millions le
prix max c'est un autre niveau l'eau
c'était un joueur est un joueur de bench
l'affecté le dernier à à chauffer le
banquier toujours jouer peut-être des
fois quand ton équipe soit gang de bouc
phare de beaucoup afin de la games fait
quand même cinq millions pour les a
commencé vrai nom c'est fou mais ça
marche après le sam à chaque la demande
c'est des gentilles lola qui sera jamais
populaire aux états unis mais c'est aux
sports le petit basque à petit ses
joueurs d'avoir à payer ce temps la
bible à grains ça se gâte bassiste pas
la même chose pour la baisse bon c'était
ma propre lapsus en 62 matchs en plein
et c'est fou le nombre de mach la maison
les revenus que ça c'est clair mais
pitié puis encore le fond on n'est pas
prêt non on regarde jamais les autres
sports pizza passé place par les fait
pas mal plus
non si on est choyé oui c'est sa
camarade des millions quoi que ce soit
quand tu es jeune tous les jeunes rêvent
à st mais la seule la plus basse c'est
quoi qui les jeunes qui rêvent à ça
c'est pas tout le monde qui a fait des
sacrifices salariaux ce soit parce que
le mont peuvent aussi la défaite qui est
acheté par acide et tu te passer bon je
te passer si je te passer ça
montrez n'importe quel qu'un jeu voilà
un personnage en clic qui pouvait la
copie conforme de skatar à thuir est
parce que les sacrifices de soldats cndd
stop il faut vraiment la tipp pour
percer là dedans c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui ça a changé parce que la
monnaie est foutrement plus rapide faut
que ce que tu adoptes c'était vraiment
serein quand tu es plus jeunes mais
d'antan que je vois que vraiment il y
avait postulé style tu es vraiment le
travailleur bout en bout de ligne qui
est récompensé pour pouvoir s'y ou non
et même chose à faire carrière
non pendant longtemps qu'ils défendent
elles à la place des hommes forts dans
les nationales puis est ce que tu es ce
que ta position par rapport à se changer
advenant elle est le fait que menace
c'est ça existe plus vraiment que
quelqu'un sait comment est-ce que cette
tension laisser faire premièrement pis
toi comment tu le veux je prends en main
j'ai toujours défendu les combos des
banquiers pour plusieurs raisons puis la
première c'est que ce qui me distingue
sur la table pour moi les jeunes filles
ce parti qui joue ok mais qui son
physique n'est ce pas les combats
restent pour avoir un euro pour eux pour
qu'ils puissent avoir un diable rouge a
toujours soit exr est la voie ou s'il
faut comprendre c'est que j'ai toujours
temps falloir qu'on enlève légaux s'ils
étaient là juste pour farce c'est des
gars qui jouent à juste deux minutes par
match mais qu'ils se battaient les
banques qui ont mené pratiquement joué
deux chefs par game où j'ai toujours
jouanno minutes par match c'est là que
ça peut être dangereux
des gars qui a marqué juste pour faire
sa barque à froid le à cause que par
lever tous égaux les bataillons descendu
à 75% pour sas qu'avec mais la chose il
faut prendre qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que qu'en 2014 d'après l'invs a parlé
dernièrement ils ont fait le même vote
constat d'appeler reste tellement à 2014
en fait un vote à travers tous les
joueurs de la ligue pour voir si oui ou
non ils voulaient voir même s'ils
voulaient enlever les batailles dans
l'attaqué parce que vous savez c'était
quoi le résultat majeur clairement
négative 98% les joueurs voulaient pas
en relève les combats dans les 90 % on
s'entend là majeurs étaient 2 ce
dimanche des joies que se sont jamais
battus ouais une quête la raison pour
laquelle ces 21 6 parce que
quand tu joues un sport de contact comme
l'arc et les mises en échec ça c'est
légal ce qui arrive souvent dans une
mise en échec joie sa femme avec des
fois les esprits s'échauffent
quand les esprits s'échauffent des fois
les joies avons jeté les gants pour
laisser tlusty mal et comme on dit et
quand ça arrive qu'on s'entend ça
n'arrivera plus en des jeux des bagarres
à l'action ce cas grec mais
qui va arriver son élève l'écran baup
les joies sont conscients d'être sexy
chick ce pack batterie commence à
l'abandon c'est ça les gones savent
qu'est ce qu'ils payent quand les
esprits s'échauffent machin croire
cheikh d'en face ou qu'un gadget les
gars il attend que jette les guerres qu
après cela tout d'abord parce que les
oies sont conscients de ces les coups
vicieux augmente si on peut tous y aura
pas de combat je me suis penché augmente
en puissance et je sache en ré que ça va
arriver
il a pas que ça va arriver si c'est à
toi que c'est la rive par un oeil arrive
de quoi comme en soirée à j'ai par la
suite
ex pour ceux que ça garde un certain
forme de code le fait que les combats
auraient cela il a commandé le commun
des mortels var but vaudois c'est trop
fou c'est trop fou trop dangereux si tu
regardes les blessés dans laquelle
curiosité le plus 20 c'est pas mal plus
par des coups vicieux que l'écran lcd
oui on va parler de shavlik offs et
blessé 15 h 15 il ya cinq ans de plus ce
qu'est ce que shane cough pensait
d'aller challenger et chine sont très
drôle d'idée
oui quand ben tu en as the wig heures
pour répondre de sa suspension qu'elle
va frapper
we go c'est en floride au lieu de
s'agripper après il ya fait son rap hip
il voulait comme square rapp avec état
grave et a vu sa s'agripper entraîneur
comme ça il reste à faire des exceptions
comme ce qui va arriver que il faut
pouvoir ramener le débat à chaque fois
parce que des exceptions comme ce qui
arrive de penser que c'est toujours
comme ça les combats finesse ou 20 par
les gars sont épuisés et puis les
arbitres séparer la règle et vous avez
les salles et les équipes aussi les
équipiers ces gamins qui se sait faire
mal on passe à autre chose et on va de
l'avant
oui ah ouais moi j'ai vraiment pensé que
justement là
c'est entre new york et à cause que le
public aime et ce plutôt ses charges et
démarches dans un linge est arrivé
quelque chose en attaque occupiez
quelqu'un fait légal georges frêche et
dont on ne sait jamais non même quand je
me battais d'antan la can avait beaucoup
de points avec ce fait de ne pas
remettre jamais battu pour le monde à
strasbourg parce qu'un besoin de ton
équipe super star le momentum si si tu
vas te faire un nom début quand et ne
recrute que les gens te crainte parce
que c'est une équipe et idées mais capte
craint on y voit remonter l'équipe
seront pas aussi faisait passer pour
vouloir c'est d'avoir à répondre un mois
des choses comme ça mais non et sinon je
vois réponse à church c'est pas comme la
loupe tout ce que tu te bats pour faire
un spectacle
non c'est parce qu'il y avait un besoin
bien jamais un coach qui m'a tapé cl
d'eau quasi compromettant la raison pour
laquelle ce n'est pas carrément
interdits outre c'est le public aime ça
c'est vraiment c'est les jo se gardent
comme cai ont fait le voc la ligue 1 en
fait le vrai plus moissinac les joies et
c'est parce que les joies les joueurs
qui se battent pas parce que c'est grâce
au sondage entre attentif et tous les
joueurs d'aller coin pour faire de façon
anonyme pourvoir ces postes à lille je
pense se sont dit mais tant que c'est
juste les enfants qui dans la majorité
bon dieu sait si on les enlève
mais non je t'aime je pense que même les
guérit étaient ils ont fait ce sondage
les deux fois il en fait une fois quand
je te laisse pas sa 2005 je me suis mis
trop
il est deux fois ces mêmes résultats car
ces sources
incroyable parce que penser aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça a déjà baissé de 75 pour
ça parce qu'il ya plus de joie de matam
ans qui vend des minutes de jeu se
battre si c'est walt sont plus là
d'abord si à des combos speed est
maintenant rendu du monde comme toi qui
joues à caixon pour être pas encore eu
d'enfant pourquoi ils seraient comme ça
c'est bien moins dangereux de se bat
aujourd'hui que dans le temps à se
battre plus qu'on dit qu'on des moments
des gars qui font ce dont je sais bien
moins dangereux donc dans le feu de
l'action même taux s'est efforcé de
temps en temps tu sais que jette les
gants
ça sera pas un beauty 6 pieds 8 275 des
mots forts qui bat avec donc c'est déjà
moins p il ya quand même des exemples
par contre des sommes folles qui ont
conduit comme cérébrale qui ont
déterminé pour nous et puis justement
fait ces gars là qui faisait juste se
battent ils se battaient constamment et
à chaque deux games et jeter les gants à
chaque thé puis c'est tout le temps pour
brûler pour brosser mais si tu enlèves
ta lève ces gens là tu réduis les soins
de 15% je connaissais pas la statistique
mais se réduit les batailles 115%
il ya pas mal moins de monde qui vont se
faire cogner sa maman est ce parce que
là tu et puis aussi de ceux qui se
battent sont moins forts - défense
d'affaires puisse pas la même chose
parce que publier quand bouaké sur des
patins c'est pas qu'on me battre sur
pied et en déséquilibre quand il tape
parce que sur patins comme souvent quand
tu regardes un combat le goy sur un pied
c'est pas la même chose avec la force
doit frapper les bains moins dur que
quand tu es sur pied pour ce que des
faut que tu regardes elle convoque ce
regard des dégâts c'est changer de
disque ou l'iton peau d'un moyen la
motoneige sur le carreau sinon ouais
efficace des folies atteint pommes et
des mines à 30 ans à quelqu'un c'est ce
que tendent à prévoir et à part peu
après 8 qui est défiguré mais au wac et
regarde ça des fois c'est long le temps
il est l'aîné par 5,5
parce que l'impact est pas si vraiment
grosse que se passe t sur pattes est est
en déséquilibre sur des lames et sueur
de larmes quand il frappe un autre pivot
petit devient sur un patin est temps d
écrire ce n'est toujours pas retombée
parce que t'es pas stable dé bonne façon
stable à se battre sur des patins donc
c'est moins dangereux qu'on pourrait
penser même si tu peux de glace est peut
être pas mal mais c'est pas évident est
ce que l'objectif c'est de mettre
l'autre chaos c'est juste du
d'irrégulier son compte un peu perplexe
car c'est un jour de gagné ouais mais
gagne en mai à avec un k o qui
s'effondra tu veux gagner d'une façon où
ce que personne tellement
sans équivoque si tu fais mal à
quelqu'un sans vraiment l'aurore mai et
le monde plus respectueux qui fêtera pas
besoin de faire aussi souvent mais siège
à votre beau dimanche de voler ou si
t'as pas mal à personne depuis que le
monde respecte ton équipe
la conséquence c'est quoi ok lui venu me
voir pour se battre at - il fait pas mal
à personne
ex pour ça que des fois tu as des
enfants dans les équipes qui se battent
plus souvent que d'autres parce que vu
que nous avons peur à personne le monde
respecte pas son équipe lui fallait tous
choqués et hagards 1
embrun toi personne n'est de voir pour
dire à lt jeu absolument battre avec
jacques c'est arrivé des recrues
bâtiment qui commence et qui le soir un
autre s'ils savaient pas trop ça des
moratoires nouveau fiers d'être jamais
arrivé si jamais arrivé que je saute
manqué pas mal d'autres ont beau mais si
je veux c'est énervant parce que je
savais qu'un joie qu'on dirait cri comme
des red bull goal admettant des recrues
phares ouais on exactement puis études à
ribou aucun intérêt cru puis je savais
qu'à demander plaidé ce qu'est le 275
sédégo demain il faut que je me prépare
en sachant que le coup tu le veuilles à
l'avenant et puis vu la soirée non plus
- fallait jouer près tout vu dans ta
carrière cette évolution là aussi pour
armand que les combats diminuaient plus
ta carrière avancées y avait moins en
moins de gras qui était de juste pour
ceux qui tuent je savais qu'il va
seulement il ya un avant - mais de
penser que c'est arrivé au point que
plus jamais on boit ça moi j'aime passé
par l'esprit parce que la seule façon
qui pourrait face à cécile vraiment
magique
du sourçage avec deux ballets après taco
dibbits acariâtre fait battre avec
quelle fréquence mettons au début de mai
de mes premières années je me bats pas
tu as 15 fois les postes 1 et c'est
certain que j'aurai passé que chaque 4
4% soit parce que
encore une fois avec l'acquéreur pittis
à tout le monde même t12 combotte le
monde voulait pas prendre de chance pas
mal ça c'est peut-être un moyen de
peut-être des choses non à quelque chose
comme ça c'est pas le nombre d'estivants
les gentils vont regarder ça ils se
battent à pau les gens parce qu'ils
comprennent pas pourquoi pour ta bave
demain ils me disent tu peux mourir où
il s'est posé d'abord qu'il y ait
nécessité il à face et que si ton et
caisse a pas respecté petit bois pas là
c'est différent
bon ça arrive la joie montréal même si
je suis toujours blessé
je pensais que j'allais y aurait jamais
fait la mise en échec à pacioretty qui a
failli le tuer il l'a fait l'année
d'après quand j'étais libéré mais sinon
quand j'étais là des gestes disgracieux
n'avait pas je mentionne joie qu'on boit
ce ton je courais après l'ugtg et que sa
glace ce serait pas mal plus pourquoi
écrire les femmes celle là je voulais
rien savoir mais quand je puis l'après
fera pas tout le monde est au même
enfant avant et couraient toujours ont
déjà entraîné des faisait plus raymond
n'était qu'un pc ça fait la présence
française que les légats les joueurs
étoiles peuvent s'exprimer pour jouer
sans avoir peur soit frappée puis que
injouable et répliques et puis ça
n'impacte que ça faisait quand on avait
un gars vraiment qu'ils étaient
respectées ça faisait qu'il ya moins de
cushing en avait pas parce que sinon si
tu fais ça à chaque fois la même chose à
te faire ton joueur étoile connaissait
d'araki mais est ce qu'ils aiment et
verbalement les gens s'insultent sur la
glace
[Musique]
la présence ou six devaient aussi calmer
son nom mais n'ont parlé parlé puis
tesla chez phare mal à quelqu'un je lui
ai jamais convaincu il m'a traité de
l'ebit word ou des délits balade ni plus
ni moins qu'à quelques tests qui
réplique le choix stoxx a fait rien le
monde sait vraiment plus et donne des
petits coups picasso de bon ton dans les
mollets et des enfants comme ceux des
coûts de cette fois être sournois
c'est la sonnerie qui rend les autres
athlètes fumay et moi j'ai jamais rien
d'un faire insulter c'était un cas où
tous les maux plus grave que ça mon sac
le sait car dans un sport de contact un
gala trafic soupiré l'homme à qui au nom
mais l'on peut arriver une fois j'en ai
vu ma vefe assomme la ligue nationale à
saint josse une fois j'en ai vista
tabarnak
oui oui tout le monde même s'il a des
tonnes alors non méchant et vista
tabarnak
non mais tous et des copies de détester
trop laxiste filtrera schiste en voir
définitivement marée noire mais envers
les francophones
des propos qui façonnent les fra cof
jouac divisia post a des jambes pour lui
c'est la seule la seule fois la seule
personne qui constate
c'est cette place-là la baignoire
les gens me regardaient les enfants je
pense qu'il va racheter iti lagarde est
peut-être jamais bien loin des 20 mars
il a en plus aux abois qui se noient les
joueurs des autres équipes les parents
des astra c'était épouvantable à tous
les jours mais cdb mais oublie sommes
rejetés comme juin un stage mais en tout
cas ce qu'ils font c'est pareil je vais
les passer dans ses mémoires dans ma
tête parce que j'ai une mission en fait
il ya personne qui va m'arrêter je sais
pas mais personne ne sait vraiment tout
en temps et en heure ce sera ton livre
qui se prenait aussi c'est que petit
talent football n'endosse pas aussi que
tu aurais probablement pu jouer à très
haut niveau aussi
mais sinon le hockey c'est plus
difficile pour moi donc je valais le la
fao si c'était le cas la république a
déjà lé staff où le jeune j'avais la
musique le carnet de jeu mais je m'en
foutais parce que j'aimais seul contact
avec au lieu de faire les jeux je
pensais des forces qui avait du monde
pour rentrer dedans puis je pense à
travers le monde avec la balance jamais
face à coraline graphique avait demandé
à quelques contacts mais la porte est
arrivé si j'avais tellement vécu de
raciste quand j'étais jeune
dans leur communiqué si j'aborde à new
york pour le football je restais un hôte
afro-américains qui réussit j'ai réussi
en tyrie stands dans la nfl
mais avec tout ce que je les les rsg
poste alors que c'est comme si tout le
monde gagne toutes les insultes m'avait
atteint ils abandonnaient leur képi jeu
donnait raison que wei ont raison aux
noix projet national avec oublie ça je
fais pas ça rex pour ce que c'est comme
ça en dirait ça pour arié brecht le nom
cfoot idec de penser comme sa carte et
enfin l'étude salée j'avais 14 ans quand
j'ai fait ces décisions là je dis non
l'admission cacher j'ai alors prouver
quel état je reste dans l'arc est qui
lance bien dans les matchs où chacun
j'ai arrêté le voit j'avais déjà ça ils
seraient gelées vu justement la scène
passe on parle de 100 corps ces médocs
le pays
licencié come stay a dit georges g10
bourgeois qui oublie pas de georges
duroy jamais rien à l'arc est un sport
de blancs ténois un avenir dans le
football un raid parler d'acquis médecin
jeudi déjà des damnés quelques années
plus tard karl menten derniers matches
et aller coacher les eskimos d'edmonton
est allé le voir danser dessus quand
j'avais 15 h le boîtier du mans c'est
comme si serge s'arrête à la venue me
voir et à chaque fois je le vois parle
de ça au parlement si soit le jeu les
vues avec c'était la classique patrice
bernier un jour sacré avec avec des
plusieurs célébrités puis et elle est un
des coaches invités mais c'est mon cas
justement avec la casse et xen visible
jusqu'à 6 ou encore des notes avec deux
andy c'est incroyable raconte tout en
six soirs le georges puis c'est juste
fou j'aurais jamais pensé que les cinq
bassins bravo pour toi mais ouais ils
sont si bien encore chez nous en nous on
a fait un sport de blancs les anguilles
la natation parce qu'il n'est pas noir
qui n'en j'ai dit c'est quand tu sois
mettons simone manuel celle qui a gagné
le saint graal à à à rio qui est noir
pis que tu que tu entends l'histoire
comme la tienne tu dis c'est tellement
c'est tellement inspirant des gens parce
que je suis sûr qu'elle a lus de
l'adversité en foule à travers tout son
parcours mais d'efforts non tu dis quoi
un box mais c'est fou parce que la
norges pour vrai pendant longtemps j'ai
pensé c'est à cause de notre le muscle à
qu'on peut répondre âgées je pense à
cause de ce bâtiment car les gens disent
que trop grosse pour tenir jusque là ne
peut pas flotter toi dis que c'est un
désavantage
quand et parce que nous on est toujours
devant être génétique elle est plus
développée que c'est plus difficile
pendant longtemps j'ai pensé que c'était
impossible jusqu'à temps que man et j'ai
vu un noir à l'équipe américaine des
organisateurs
je vois des choses que ça mais c'est
quand même beaucoup non j'ai encore
moins noir dans la même façon que dans
l'heure qu'il est c'est rama
l'impression qu'ici que c'est c'est
strictement culturel
j'ai l'impression que c'est strictement
culturel
c'est ce qu'un jeune droit qui grandit y
voit plus s'identifier au basket-ball -
c'est ce qu'envisage mais j'imagine n'y
a pas vraiment de la génétique aussi
sombre en maintenant le sprint le 100 m
il ya plus de noirs qui vont qui font ce
que les blancs thématique chaque sport
ou s'il ya des
la génétique rendre dans balance mais
aussi triste vraiment moi je pense que
je pense que si on parle de toner
musculaires sont sûres du 50 et du 100
mètres sur du sprint ça change rien aux
notations dont la natation le sprint ça
change rien n'est fait que je me dis
prend le manque d exemple je demande
comme simone manuelles comme toi oui
c'est des exemples pour ce que les
jeunes afro américain comfort pack et
c'est possible le chemin avant 6h
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment positif en
fait le est-ce que plus de noirs
maintenant dans la ligue nationale qui à
l'époque prend la main ouailles à ne
plus oublier non plus il ya beaucoup de
pilotes aussi mais quand il a été
considéré comme noah cause que la race
noire est plus proéminente mais qu'il y
en a beaucoup c'est francis bouillon il
a beaucoup de monde c'est un peu quitte
à noire québécoise
oui mais il m'appelait qui savent pas
danser et et latinos non bien pleines
mans qui pensait pas ici et puis on
était la tâche la gauche il ya beaucoup
mon ton qui était même surpris quand je
leur disais il ya même du monde reste
que c'est les offusqués de savoir web et
bien sa chance et si c'est mme lalonde
l'aide de négatif que piquet ça va aussi
c'est sur l'édition comme ça mon gars
parce que vu qu'ils étaient plus
flamboyante monk et arras est ce qui m a
pour sa part loué des délais de 10 euros
ce matin les équipes où sa vamp sommet t
il faut quand même d'avoir 4 à 2019
aujourd'hui il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire 4-4 a du succès tu
deviens une cible automatique de ces
propos le gia matin même je lisais
imposs instagram de tom morello tom
morello c'est le guitariste de jazz de
mes chaînes puis maintenant il fait des
projets de musique seul puis entre
plaindre aux demandes qui lui sont pas
renier puisqu'il est pas son temps est
vraiment moche pas équitable ouais c'est
ça puis sauf que lui qui ya fait un
pause puis sur le post est quelqu'un qui
disait arrête de prendre la parole
t pain blanc plus on pose qui expliquait
ses qui disait le monde toute ma vie
j'ai été profilés toute ma jeunesse
j'étais profiler pour la couleur mon
père pour mes cheveux
le monde voulait toucher mes cheveux il
dit quand j'ai été quand je devenu
populaire
tout le monde mon identifié comme blanc
alors que l'eau sachant pilote quand je
dis aux gens qui m'aiment que je suis
noir
il ya plein de gens qui acceptent qu'il
passe est sûre parce que ça vient
ils sont racistes qui peuvent pas aimer
mon raisonnement
non tu as raison ça sent pas sans raison
que la foi de france et rémi sella plein
d'athlètes comme ce que le monde sont
pas trop se piquer ses deux succès non
comme jérôme huguet way monde qui me
pose c'est de savoir quand on part être
noir sa marée blanche
non et je dirai qui tu es considéré
comme un noir et des choses comme ça que
c'est fou
telle une vague dure à quillan qui
encadrent des mentalités et qui tend de
notre époque l'agression on peut
vraiment pas exclusivement aux harkis
métier et récemment jeté l atome on en
parle pour ça avec l'athlé delà de la
ligue
réseau paris méricaine si on parle de
moi saint-girons dans des ligues ou ce
que ya pas vraiment de contrôle du monde
qui cherchent la bagarre est pas encore
tout à fait bonne réputation tant que
seconde la demande
ce vin qui vont d'avoir ces matches à
certains endroits et sa promesse cas de
l'action des estrades
ouais c'est juste pour te fait que mais
assez s'améliorer le stopper dans le
temps dans le temps c'était cette ligue
est ce qui était radio x encore une
équipe qui existe ou non je le suis à
l'époque les radio x bah en fait c'était
l'année du leurre car depuis de nombreux
chiens étaient avait rejoint la radio
etc cependant cette année là c'était
comme la star parce qu'ils battaient
piteux mondial à barcelone mais moi j'ai
jamais voulu aller là dedans parce que
tu ne te récemment pu faire des années
là dedans après oui mais ce pas cela
parce qu'il y oppose testerait de la
douane qui se battent à kadhafi
ah oui sarko dans quelques pièces à 6
francs
c'est trop dangereux
23 perdre là-dedans si je le peux mais
tenace en jeu dans ses comptes qu'un
gars qui absolument rien à perdre tout
espoir a donc sauté dessus tout le temps
pour chacun joue là dedans c'est a pas
vraiment bête s'est battue bec une 2 x
max gros joueurs et est un gars qui joue
en national en place de projets seraient
ainsi tout le monde s'est embourgeoisé
voulait pas se battre et cela passe
blessés mais cet armement dire parmi
l'élite l'an pièce après tu es bon josas
a pas été bon pour lui ce qui est arrivé
en arriver au 10 avait fait toute une
histoire la team
si tu peux jamais parlé tantôt te dit tu
utilises expression une ligue de balle
il ya quelque chose autour du rentier
que moi me rejoint beaucoup plus que
certains autres sports
l'espèce de teuf naissent d'un joueur de
kiel l'espèce de commequiers ses
contacts
on fait pour fêter c'est extrêmement mal
bulle de sang blanc peut-être frappé les
caméras tout le monde c'est comme tu te
fais insulter les tirs mais dans
d'autres sports on dirait quand il pas
dû au fait que tout le monde voit la
reprise c'est quand même il faut pas
toucher la chique au basket c'est
prendre un petit mot j'adore regarder le
basket et de la misère avec le monde qui
font semblant qui crie après l'arbitré
yolk ont toutes les cales à chaque fois
qu'ils en caoutchouc puis c'est ce qui
m'interpelle - le plus haut chiffre
d'affaires à qui on peut dessus juste
jouer même si wii ware décalque du match
aller mais peu de souplesse que tu dis
c'était brad copeland aux sports c'est
au coeur soir
grandel enfin oui il y avait ils
reviennent y avait un clip d'ovechkin
qui étaient aux banques été superposées
un clip s'était passé la même journée un
club de soccer le gars qui tombe tout
seul en trébuchant estime tibio
camarades doivent être signés support la
bande
il ya une peau qui arrive kif gens qui
regardent la scène poker is à fait clair
que je sauvegarde et lloyd tirage du
même pôle le pacs il ya un pas que ça
arrive vite les dents longues à pékin sa
manière et mes coéquipiers leinster sont
en deçà de frapper des correspondances
faciles à comparer à l'asse d'un tir ton
cinglant 6 1 qui lâchait à chaque chef
us command et mike rami reçoit bon ton
en face je vois avec dialogues ça dans
le noir à marsan à il monte - klaus a
pas la télé et d'un ça dans chevelure
rousse a glass works est reconnue pour
sauter train de jouer avec la tafna
situent les potes peu près toujours dans
la capitale ce propos sincères connu les
jours drac ecomax on t'offre comment
joie que la douleur comme un petit bloc
de lancer et piquionne pop qui reste
l'europe c'est juste normal qu'après un
match encore à son remplacement
c'est incroyable c'est des gars et puis
c'est vrai que des fois que je regarde
au sport il a sacrément sports a préféré
puis oui c'est un sport physique mais
des fois la fécafoot le monde qui
plongent pour avoir un quart des
arbitres - ou même au basket c'est que
c'est facile de plongée puis de laisser
tomber tout dégringole même il faut que
je trouve que c'est embarrassant
ouais c'est ça moi c'est ce que spie
mais moi ce que je comprends pas c'est
pourquoi est ce que les personnes qui
font ça sont pas plus pointés du doigt
c'est moi mettons admettons qu à chaque
fois que je fais car le titre est
federer est tout et des moyens c'est à
chaque fois c'est qu'on arrête arrête là
mais c'est glacé kampaï le fait
d'enquêter chris paul des rockets de
houston ne lui est reconnu pour être lui
qui floppe le plus le cas flop c'est
comme mon coude pas ça soit à face si tu
te fais comme si je frappe à face à
s'aimer serbie maintenant on a des
reprises vidéo
t on est capable de france cif ou non
mais c'est que maintenant les laisser
des amendes pour servir gestes pratiques
chez mais il y en a tellement que ça
serait que je pense que leur temps
j'adore les amendes à s'user tellement
ça serait tellement hors contrôle
le chat car ces problématiques la france
accueille appelé n'gaous que ouais c'est
sûr que c'est quand il mange à coups de
pied ventes a ralenti bien ça donne mais
qui moss thomassin après un couple de
menotter correct mais dans beaucoup de
cas où ça que les gosses font vraiment
pas cheap dans la boîte le monde plonge
à lewis et ça parce que tu tirais
analytics au jade quatre majeurs ou
psychosociales morts au moins et roulé
pendant quelques coups mais voulait
vraiment des tonneaux à temps partagé
des carrières venu pour jouer pour le
psg apparaît samilia envie d'en acheter
ouais mais ils ont averti qu'ils ont dit
le soc c'est vraiment mauvais lyon 10 de
plus face les recharges un peu mais ils
ont été avertis d'aplomb parce que
c'était mauvais pour lui puis pour
l'heure pour nec
vous savez pas de bon sens mon part et
d'autre comme mais inversement est ce
que ce côté là un peu plus rough du rock
et des mises en échec des bateaux et
sepideh
imagine qu'ils aient quelque chose qui
rebute bien du monde aussi inutile puis
peut-être qui sait je sais pas d'où son
nom qui fait que ces pauvres
aux etats unis aussi populaire que
met-on basket ou crédoz pas peut-être
que non mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle la qui pose pas plus que les
espaces passe à coacher équipes
auxquelles les basques emballant de
sölden et le rock et sa coach à qui les
minorités qui viennent en amérique je
n'en ont pas les moyens
autour de 6 100 piasses je m'équipe et
puis à cet âge là mais d'après fo qui
change ton équipement complet par la
grande idée notamment ses seuls
problèmes ou occupent la voûte et ça
coûte trop cher sa première chose qu'ils
n'ont pas attendre ses 250 grammes un
lit les parents n'ont pas les moyens
c'est la première raison c'est ça la 12e
n'y a pas d'homme role models et le
paralyse taylor qui est étiqueté pour un
sport de blancs le cas par an qui te
lèves ce qui reste son enfant qui veut
sans avances ou élevé dans la ouate
comme on dit est-ce qu'il va devait
inscrire mon kit dans leurs acquis puis
son rôle modèle voix
un gars qui est retraité ou un cas n'est
pas trop les joueurs sont allés passer
n'a tellement pas piqué puis à montréal
des clôtures garde ce n'était pas trop
courant mais ce qui se passe et il n'y a
pas beaucoup de rôles modèle de mons et
craquer ce transportable ans si je
prends une chance le maître loeb qui
soit exposé aux racistes et les
attendent au rabbit les affaires qui
arrivent les parents l'équipement des
enfants de ceux qui voient cette suite
avant même qu'elle en phase one et avec
ce qui se passe propre agenda larqué ne
peut l'exposer à ça avec déjà de là
l'idée préconçue claqué pop up pour les
noirs se pare de blanc m'a plu à slick
manque aux charges futures une nouvelle
constamment c'est pour ça que la guinée
c'est trop compliqué et il est noir
normalement on est hyper actif de nature
pour notre génétique éclaté mais dans un
sportif un jour sans que la question
fait bouger beaucoup c'est plus simple
pas de lörrach et rappelé les familles
canadiennes halak et ex voici les
maîtres des enfants dans un sport que ce
même pas patiné tout en un qui sera pas
une montre et un je veux percer la peau
parce qu'ils sont arrivés d'haïti
l'avantime était de manteaux d'hiver
qu'elle ne voit joie qui cache ses
cadres et je parle de raclée aussi par
les chinois et j'étais tout seul la
dengue connaissait aucun joueur est né
sans l'arrière des personnes un il ya
des parties les parents carlina
aujourd'hui regardez leur quête leurs
parents kennedy sont zappé au sol un
oubli sans regarder passage tu es tout
seul tu es le seul à y croire vraiment
la fixe pour ça que c'est pour apprendre
la question c'est juste du sein dans ce
cas une version créée division 2 de
pouvoir faire la queue kahn est plus aux
états unis pressent françois plus
accessibles les minorités à dà nang
stock adonnant l'équipement de rats qui
aura marqué plus pop là pour qu'ils
montent un peu plus les mets toi c'est
comment tu commences hygen tu dis moi si
le hac et que je fais quand chamand il
n'y a pas vraiment de modèle et para
t'encourage peu car quand tu es jeune
promo pas de couleur quant à la fin de
mon été
et moins jeunes à montréal 4-1 il ya
soirée albecq tout le monde voulait
tourner nationale mais moi qui à partir
de 5 ans l'assemblage des jo pour joie
que dans la rue puis pendant l'hiver il
assistera dans un petit parc
on fait ça tous les jours on vous
laissera national feicom genou au mois
de décembre plus j'adore le froid le
death by en plus des tests l'été il joua
catch les jours dans les puissances
arabes c'est comme ça que ça commençait
les jeunes
le dow jones a gagné 1 6%
eminem le pourcentage pour les as - pour
sa belle maman est classé secret ce qui
est possible c'est d'écarter jeune site
va trembler les chances sont tellement
les autres gagnent pratiquement dès que
ça va arriver tellement que c'est des
millions d'ipad 2 millions des millions
des des jeunes le 4 4 à 5 ans petit
soient les leurs et combien de jeunes
des cinq ans que disent les moins fort
que toi et est tellement millions il y
avait le tournoi pee wee du carnaval de
québec un homme est atteint mais moi je
dirais c'est moins pea si je pense
d'accord plutôt zen aux olympiques
voilà j'en sais encore plus tough que
pour nous non je sais la porte comme un
agent qui représente le canada parce que
c'était un jour dans une nacelle mais
même pas mais ton était à ses yeux
plusieurs épreuves par équipes
nationales genre 15h15 fissures garçons
et 15 canadiennes y est plus que quatre
canadiens mais qui en a disons qu'à
natation au canada le peuple qui au
canada est vraiment énorme
c'est à peu près que camille 15
personnes mettant 15 go qui vont aux
olympiques pour le canada mais c'est que
chaque pays en ont aussi ouais
j'imagine que c'est comparable en termes
de pourcentage de chance les jeunes qui
sont gentils le bassin y mettons le sur
un million de personnes prend le maquis
à peu près une impression suivront des
statuts que je connais pas mais j'ai
l'impression que ça doit tourner ph
beaucoup plus que moi
noah et puis encore moins si j'ai pas le
temps quelqu'un qui regarde ceux d'un
troisième point de vue extérieur j'ai
passé proche
mais quand tu connais vraiment ce
j'avais juste parce qu'il fallait sujet
puis rapidement je lis sud au mexique
est aussi aussi temps de parler de
génétique et ça rentre dans balance mise
au point et spin bike défi oui des
guenons ont des gars n'ont pu cesser
e on parlait de la nba tantôt laitiers
j'écoute une entrevue avec jerry
indiquent des services sexuels de finale
et phoebe lui disait
qu' il était content d'être justice et
cap parce qu'il se fait pas trop
reconnaître dans rue metsys et 4 et gran
mais lui à 6 et 4 un petit joueur de
basket de l'outil comme vraiment qui
c'est une des choses que j'aime aussi du
rock et c'est que des joueurs plus
petits qui peuvent se rendre le 10 sport
que vraiment c'est pas la génétique tes
chansons mauvaise vraiment la natation
c'est anticipant le voit ce qui était
des michael phelps on en parlait juste
en début de procast ian thorpe et si
c'est de la grosse génétique
si markov a tous ici c'est plutôt en
parlait justement des
tous les sacrifices qu'il faut faire
pour se rendre ces objectifs le puits
mais c'est m et un 100 m nationale si
c'est encore juste une poignée parmi
ceux qui ont fait tous les sacrifices
d'une impressionnante et il faut tout
donner ce qu'on nomme hemayma si t'as
pas la garantie
sauf que la chose qui arrive c'est que
s'il ya maintenant tu fais tu essaies
qui précède doctorants de la nasa n'a
pas tout donné c'est que si tu ris
points soit il ya deux ans les chances
de son côté il ya tellement gens que je
parle aujourd'hui qui vivent avec des
regrets parce qu'ils savent qu'ils n'ont
pas toujours fait les bonnes décisions
aujourd'hui déjà la fête devant dijon
l'a réussi comme toujours mieux être
fixé en sachant que des taux maximum
loeb est ton rêve à se dévier vers autre
chose que de demander ou si j'arrête du
si j'arrête dit pas si j'allais 10
passes
c'est ça qui arrive les gens oublient
ceux de penser à ce qu'il fasse pour
vraiment continuer tes une mauvaise
décision peut impacter choix de carrière
c'est pour ça que c'est tellement
important de rester faut que ce soit
vraiment moi tu vois je te manges
arrêter la natation se fait longtemps ça
fait dix ans si j'arrêtais après
secondaire à 16 ans mais tous tous tout
cet entraînement le tout est clean lui
que j'ai fait tous les sacrifices que
j'ai fait mais je parlais aux olympiques
même si je peux payer pris soudainement
nombre de mandats notation mais moi ce
que ça m'a apporté ce que sa mort
comment ça m'a forgé comme personne je
recommencerai lâcherait le même parcours
le truc changera rien
c'est clair qu'un qui capte commencé à
militer pour les animaux puis que tu
n'aies on ne connaissait pas du tout
pour se montre que l'un sur quelqu'un
qui se battait l'opinion globale ou la
vision globale des gens qui
connaissaient d'annoncer qu'un homme
fort mali nationale qui se moquent
d'autres renforts puis quand j'ai
commencé à militer pour les animaux avec
un client entre autres l'art victorien
4e prix la catho faite le la narration
est ce que tu dis ce que tu as senti un
espèce de discréditation certaines
personnes à douala il se bat contre les
humains et puis se bat pour les animaux
il condamne la violence envers les
animaux mais ils peuvent y être mais
quand les gens faisaient ils ont arrêté
assez vite de me pose la question car
j'ai répondu oui je leur disais que
c'est totalement épais camara marque
puis ceux qui nous écoutent en ce moment
mais je leur dis si ceux qui pensent
comme axes étaient exercées je me
battais condé doit creuser des millions
de dollars qui étaient consentants peut
comparer ça des animaux qui sont en
ligne pourrait se faire égorger qui sont
en gros certains ne sont pas payés les
tués avaient cependant ils sont encore
en vie peux-tu me reposer la question
grâce n'aura qu'un seul hic ce pays
arabes nous avons été rejoints
emilia mac jeu des millionnaires qui
était quête qui d'un contrat venait le
voir comme il est alors jobs way et
c'est pour ça que c'est déjà arrivé avec
savoir vraiment il est vraiment tout ce
que j'ai entendu dans cette mine est le
cas je peux pas m'arrêter de du témoin
fait faux
ça fait un an et demi que je fais gagne
puis que je t'en parle
puis j'ai déjà l'impression d'avoir fait
le tour
c'est déprimant qu'on m'a donné tout
leur mentant à longueuil n'ont pu savoir
non non ça c'est les mêmes qui
reviennent toujours mais
la question des prothèses osterloh ma
famille mais c'est vrai qu'en un an et
demi ça fait le tour c'est toujours la
même chose qui tissent fait beaucoup de
conférences le sujet ce qui au début
j'en faisais encore plus j'en faisais
une fois par mois au début quand je
donne et vegan il
ce que je voulais faire c'est que je
voulais rattraper le temps perdu par je
me disais pendant des années je savais
pas que j'étais jean dausset toutes ces
industries et j'ai commencé à faire des
des visionnements publié screen
d'aborder dans les cinémas le premier
j'ai faite au blues aux jeux olympiques
jo j'ai payé salles de cinéma pour le
faire jouer avec deux milieux titre
électrique un député à varier le monde
le monde dans ce round
parce que pour le lancement jeu là de
quoi de gros jeux [ __ ] et les grammys aux
shoots il fallait le président se soit
plaint josette série des chandails du
canadien à la fin annoncée au début ça
allait geler la savate à trois noms mais
l'ex n avait pas mal de chardy est fait
ça pendant un an à chaque mois je les
fait à l'uqam ou si j'ai rappelé l'uqam
je les fais de la boxe il était venu
pour ça discute est drôle c'est que à
chaque fois que je faisais à soyaux
moins que mais personne au moins dans
les 10 km avec ça n'allait pas cesser
drama devra garder la retraite ce qui
est fou c'est que je me souvienne ogouz
au fait je n'ai pas c'était quoi
vraiment ce n'est pas la gare d'arqués
qui le montre dans ce qui ôte ses lavis
âmes en public
c'est le nouveau la sensibilité du
public ce que pensaient les gens pour
qui les entend plus le sens ça mais
comme une énergie dans la saq incroyable
piquant les visas mans est finie c'est
une conférence après plus de tellement
fortement à terre que maintenant le saut
où va écouter le peuple a parlé quand il
parle de végétal is as du monde
curieux comme ceux ouais c'est pas la
même chose que quand yvon vieu
documentera comme sac d
le tessin d'essence vous et tu leur
parles j'ai fait ça pendant un an puis
vraiment je vais y aller salle les gens
c'était grave finalement
je paie les sages les tirages à la fin
des prix de présence pour le monde reste
il en un an quand j'ai fait seul se
décrit comme un mouvement montréal de
plus en plus de restaurants vegan ça le
gros c'est une émulation le grossiste et
si fou ce que ça l'ait fait tout a vu le
changement
c'était incroyable simone amerrir wap
moyen de cessation végétarienne comment
que ça l'est waldis l'homme de personne
qui a commencé à embarquer comment que
les gens commencent à changer puisque
c'est le fait lui a commencé à voir
d'autres personnes c'est comme toi comme
table on paie d'autres influences à égal
qu'ils sont qui sont venus au début ne
s'était plus rendu quelque chose qui
était un salaire que le monde se
demandait c'est quoi ce n'est les gens
commencent à comprendre qu'elle veut de
plus en plus qui en avaient qu'il
l'était qui voulait pas s'afficher avant
qu'ils avaient plupart s afficher
massacrer mais jouer pour le canadien
depuis sa fiche
il veut tout le monde commence à en
parler la salle a créé un mouvement
puisse cette incroyable
le commentaire des manèges qui remplit
du monde là-dedans dans ces choses là
pis pour l'heure mouvementée pour les
animaux c'était juste incroyable ça
continue encore un
c'est vraiment et c'est l'fun parce que
tu vois la relève soit le monde conclut
pas de se prononcer là dessus alors
qu'avant c'était pas mal plus tabou on
s'entend il ya cinquante ans c'était
quelque chose maintenant aujourd'hui de
s'engager cela restera vegam à montréal
comme rihanna comment que ça grossit les
options klô pelgag surtout obligé
d'avoir une section parce que sinon ils
vont perdre du monde repart des clients
c'est juste le iga les jeunes en avant
des biens burger est incroyable il n'y
avait pas le choix aux états unis
vendent plus de ce que la vie la vraie
viande c'est quand même comment c'est
les gens sont en train d'évoluer
il faut c'est que quand je regarde ça tu
dis que la population change les les
c'est l'aîné des gens évoluent c'est
souvent le thé la nouvelle génération
qui change la vieille génération souvent
usage uniquement de ma vie changerait
pas une nouvelle eu le maillot jaune
donne l'exemple
on voit des gros changements yao avoriaz
tanger-ville cochon dingue et nouveaux
médias
j'étais allé j'avais un an comment ce
garçon en fin de semaine puis on est
allés au et w12 de trucs qui les deux
soeurs des gars avec qui on n'étaye ont
pris bien mais il mangeait rien dit les
deux rien moi j'ai juste pris mes
marques
les deux tiers ont pris ça juste parce
qu'il est disponible oui aussi comme
celle c'est la même chose pour que c'est
la même chose autrement mais des screen
comme ceci ces fous pareils que tu as
décidé de faire ce pas affectés on
s'entend therrien s'est pas c'est pas un
documentaire d'entrée d'entrée en
matière le support un étouffement les
deux amants mais parce que la phase bêta
raison sic
si le prix documentaire a montré à
quelqu'un ce qui devait lever gagnent ou
est-ce que c'est trop c'est trop c'est
trop
exactement puis la rejeter déjà que la
regarda rights a pas de cendres
c'est juste ça m'a pris deux fois ça m'a
pris deux fois je l'écouté j'arrêtais
des shadoks est là c'est assez menarini
détachage de gauche au début tu te
laisses en anglais c'est oit
confédération quand je les ai vus c'est
ce qui m'a fait des vagues anne au
québec le monde connaissait pas trop ce
document talent parce que tu en anglais
le monde dit en français c'était le
documentaire anglais que des succès
le clan j'ai commencé à parler de haute
link c'est là que le changement en scène
le producteur de klinsmann appelé du
coup sûr pas la nation française et qui
venait à montréal jeudi
c'est quelque chose a pris 75 ans fait
la narration française darling j'avais
deux professeurs de français avec moi il
fallait crèche
les textes ont été traduits ouais
traduit tous les textes parce que
l'anglophone en titre a dû au complet en
français
d'après ce que je lis les textes avec
les images times est parfaitement faux
tu revois les images sans arrêt je
pourrais le site rajoute à rien sans
volume puis je préfère la narration le
complet lorsqu'on voit tellement que ça
à prix d'or
ouais affaire que j'oublie pas et au
début
au début parce qu'on s'attend à un
marché de mes amis sont payants et le
mco qui ont fait d'études et les
concessions quittait coupent la viande
rouge de sauge comme ça mais ils sont
pas tus pas assez intense au coupé mes
amis qui sont pas obligatoires à
puymoyen
mais une chose par exemple que j'ai fait
c'est tous mes amis les gens dans mon
entourage avec un cache pas que j'étais
ami avec je leur ai dit allez au moins
qui coûte la femme parce que je veux
savoir ce qu'ils comprennent mon nouveau
cheminement mais qu'à l'industrie et
endossait pour m'assurer vraiment qu'il
ait vu je l'écoutais avec moi je les ai
vus peut-être terrible nouvelle fois
peut-être avec tout le monde juste près
tout ce qu'il voit que les gens
comprennent
au lieu qu'ils posent deux questions est
ce que tu peux aussi parce que les
manifestations produit voilà pourquoi
j'ai l'air pourquoi les yeux et ma mère
surtout maman a capoté le profit tue les
manifs le move ont par les comptes web
de toute façon c'est à cette cause de
mon côté c'est une siècle avait gagné ce
manuel en mettant ça que vous ouvrez les
veines et pensez vraiment que c'est
quelque chose de néfaste dégâts soudan -
1 mais pas celle que j'allais mourir
mais déjà des carences mais c'est parce
que c'est ce que les gens de l'extérieur
dix mecs pour ce que celles en bout de
ligne ce que les gens disent c'est fou
parce que avant que je sois vegan je
pensais comme ça aussi magicien je
pensais comme ça puis quand je suis
devenu le hsv conférence parce que quand
les gens posent des questions je me
voyais à leur place avant mais j'avais
juste jamais donné une chance je n'ai
jamais dans mon esprit à me renseigner
là dessus ni barebone isba raconte que
je teste ses perpignan puis j'essaie
juste déclaré les gens que les gens
qu'ils sont s'ils réussissent à
comprendre les raisons qui à la
différence que ça fait aujourd'hui petit
le bienfait aussi parce que tellement
intentionnistes dire qu'il faut que je
mange provoc mais besoins nutritionnels
clic est c'est fait que parce que c'est
quand même important parce que c'est
possible d'avoir des carences qui doit
manger un morceau de phrase parce que
j'avais exactement égal ils ouvraient
chapeau comme à chaque fois c'est
absolument rien je frise échéant bosta
coin et du pacs aux argos thackwell
choses comme ça car et d'avoir un mari
roy m'a aidé pour me donner
début parce que je me documente h allée
chez nous tous avaient déposé à nîmes en
tunisie dans le sac donné ça les paumes
jeudi je mange quoi
le cam a vraiment aidés qui en plus mais
ce que j'aime et plus et quand j'étais à
l'institut de cardiologie j'étais chez
nous le voir sur youtube gâcher la vie
en bois puis à l'extrait là dessus
depuis j'ai fait des tests avant et
après ils vraiment le puits même lui
laisse pas que les tests physiques que
j'ai fait avant et après les tests de
100pts c'est incroyable la différence
que ça les fait juste en adoptant un
mode de vie végétale et ans dans des
quatre mois seulement fait pour ce que
tu es après avoir fait des essais
jeuland hausse après les gens parlaient
parce que j'ai une grande différence
pour longtemps après j'ai investi tant
que la sens que finalement c'est plutôt
normal et puis c'est fermé puis j'en ai
un nouveau resto maintenant j'ai fait
lire essayèrent ton nouveau resto oui
mais bon j'ai pris le pool est allé mais
ouais dit xavier dernier qui est scanné
qui longerait l'autoroute elle mangeait
chez eux qui lui est faite le switch
pour les performances
puis initialement c'était pour les
performances puis après ça il ya pris
connaissance des enjeux environnementaux
des enjeux éthiques
puis si comme ce qu il l'est resté parce
que si tu le fais juste pour les
performances une faute à carhaix
finistère en faut un petit j'ai
l'impression que tout le temps tu
rentres pas un des trois aspect
futuriste pour les autres souvent oui
mais non mais c'est ce que 6 et pour les
autres c'est exact est-ce que tu as d'un
projet de chèques et une coupe d'autres
documentaires à la terrien mais à saveur
du jour si on veut comme dominion entre
autres est-ce que tu eu l'intention
d'impliquer dans quelques heures la
traduction tête notamment d'affaires je
sais qu'il sait quoi le documentaire a
manqué tous et les meilleurs si les gars
qui se promènent le dal et voilà ça
c'était du camp sara fille il paraît que
les petits gars vous menez vous avez
watts a cédé 15 mois moissinac mental je
trouve c'est la meilleure il y brille et
il sait pas celle d'entrée mais il est
quand même controversé au niveau des
faits pourquoi c'est pourquoi
parce que je voudrais les soeurs des
faits moi ce que j'aime c'est qu'à
legault bah si c'est ce qui est
intéressant jusqu'au quai ans qui doit
qui rend sa 7e cancer puis il fait juste
ita ducati la gueule c'est la trêve il
sait pas que legault soirée fête ses 10
ans et à 6 à chaillevette est contenté
d'avoir une entrevue de parler de son
centre dans les dix ultimes intitulé
pourquoi dans votre site dites aux gens
de manger de la viande et des produits
laitiers à laquelle beaucoup d'études
ont discuté c'est pas bon pour sa cause
le cancer
legault est dit car at il dit on a les
réponses comprendra pas répondre avec
étude pour le groupe la séquence qui
après ou location qui demandent est ce
que c'est parce que on regarde les
partenaires comment ces compagnies là la
patte encore plus pratique quand tu
attends sol même si le détail des choses
science mais comme tu dis qu'ils sont
pas prouvés mais je sais réaction le
noir à trois gros cendres au monde qui
sont reconnus s'ils voient ça de
l'extérieur en tentant toujours souvent
dit que la viande des bons vins doit pas
de problème inverse la l'est pas
toujours d'al gore qui peut pas répondre
pis pour le godard se regarde sa petite
vie un problème c'est pour ça que j'ai
trouvé ça autre côté le wydad à
confronter la personne ne sait ce que ce
que j'ai aimé le pluzz droite de m
c'est vraiment les camps qu'ils voient
sur les i d'une étude maison qui dit que
prouve que les u6 bien puis là il va
voir qui a financé l'étude c'est les
producteurs doit c'est vraiment
s'intéresser aux côtés de l'abbé un
glock et j'ai quoi ce qui souligne qu il
lui en manque pas eu un été à chaque
fois il vérifie qu subventium séquence
puisqu'il est aujourd'hui sec
pour que le gouvernement lève la tête la
catégorie des produits récemment comment
la société les volumes garde l'argent
que les producteurs laitiers ont perdu à
cause de cette décision sûrement et non
pour qu'ils enlèvent ste catherine en
sachant que ça les facettes un tacle il
faut tu vraiment que ça sent pas bon
pour la santé est pas le choix de le
faire alors qu'on sait que le
gouvernement fait tout ce qu'il peut
pour avoir le plus d'argent possible
pécs pour sa commandite digue la société
vraiment évolué lui maintenant
aujourd'hui à l'épicerie on voit bien
plus substitut delek de lait de vache
mais passé ce seuil en série ont rempli
de substituts malades paris il ya 50 ans
tu aurais jamais pensé ça d'aujourd'hui
ça prend le dessus complètement sa
montre comme quoi les gens évoluent pour
moi tant qu'à moi je trouve que
l'engouement de la santé si oui un
briquet nutritionniste vont vont
recommander une diète riche en végétaux
le plus possible 6e mondial peu de
viande qui est au bord de l'eau sopi
éviter les produits transformés ça
revient toujours
mais je pense quand même à ce que pour
ma part qu'il l'argument environnemental
l'argument des tic animales sont plus
forts plus convaincant parce qu'il ya
moins une zone grise triple point parce
que peu de choses et oui ma vegans peut
aussi très mal manger puis mangeuse de
viande ne sera pas forcément c'est plus
du domaine de l' objectif parce que
l'éthique animale c'est plus au niveau
des émotions et tandis que l'éthique
animale c'est vraiment très objectif
bush deux images saisies therrien jeux
d'écouté pitié
je capable d'en prendre le fallait
regarder à côté mais c'est la seule
chose c'est que c'est vrai ce que tu dis
là qu'il ya des gens qui sont victimes
engagement et ma juste des usa son
audience et paca face à ces mines manger
de la viande que ce match juste des
mutations bien où est la chose par
exemple c'est quand je fais des
conférences où se rendit compte c'est
que je parle d'éthique animal
l'environnement les gens s'en foutent la
soirée l'homme sent apte à être
exactement parce que l'environnement est
dit dans ce sens tant chez plus le
l'éthique allemand dispose actuellement
fou mais la ressentais quand je vois là
dedans c'est le gym une différence le
monde écoute quand ce pardon animaux qui
sauf ils s'en foutent c'est incroyable
sur ce les gens sont immenses en fait
nan et puis quand je passais juste
probablement changer comment j'ai fait
maintenant par juste la santé je prends
même pas vraiment ça donne à rien le
monde s'en foutent ils dire si la
propagande c'est pas vrai à son décor et
axa des races et je reste c'est comme ça
que les gens pensent vraiment pas ça
dépend vraiment pas là des gènes de
l'environnement les gens sont plus sont
plus maintenant conscientiser les
dickens image après tout tu te montres
tes rien à dire en personne puis c'est
vraiment j'ai l'impression que quelque
chose
si une personne ne le prend pas tic
[ __ ] jamais vu si tu savais pas su
comme toi toujours la note la plus salée
switcher certaines personnes vont faire
tout ou rien
d'autres enfin ça dépend ce n'est pas
tiré d'affairé c'est trop c'est trop
mais c'est pas c'est pas la meilleure
façon non moi j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours pensé qu'une méthode douce
positive parce que si je te demande si
tu attends qu elle met ton comme
jean-philippe fait état mais me direz
c'est trop douce dans les choix aux gens
les gens au québec
c'est cette fois un peu ils vont rire
ok devons manger un big mac a prêté par
les combats il faut que ça soit à ces
chocs mais rien c'est laid trop
c'est tellement du rembourrage d'écran
c'est tellement trop de sujets comme on
y dispense aux factures gagnait fender
rhodes sur ses pas et que c'est vraiment
pour ça que ouais il y avait un
documentaire espagnol que c'est
le véganisme vu par un sceptique je n'en
avais plus et commencé comme en commun
qui s'appelle puis legault au début ils
peuvent également que son ami qu'il est
le lui il a décidé de faire un
documentaire sur sa recherche par
rapport à ceux puis tu vois jamais de
d'animaux mourir tu vois jamais sauf que
sous-entend avec des avec différents
graphiques les trucs comme ça puisse lie
d'amitié avec avec un mouton un certain
temps qui va visiter une ferme d'élevage
pleut comme suit un peu le raisonnement
en sachant très bien où ça va finir puis
ça finit exactement où ça va finir
il fait la comparaison avec son chien
tout au long tout au long du film et
qu'on parle de brebis à son chien pilote
comprend qu'à fin il colle son chien
puis tribu le gain qui se rend compte
que qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce je les
trouvais bon j'ai trouvé que c'était si
j'y repense je mettre le lien dans
déception pour ceux qui veulent checker
sûr mais maintenant c'est sûr mais je
pense que pour y aller doucement mais il
faut malgré tout un éveil quelconque ici
suscité un éveil l'agression a suscité
quelque chose qui peut comme hawaii
abouti comme on dit c'était sympathique
mais ne m'étais jamais vu qu est-ce qui
est derrière tout ça parce que je ne
vois pas comme si on disait les gens
m'ont dicté jusqu'à la fin moi si ce
décès est sage jouer dans leur esprit
point ils vont trancher
ça c'est la faute à la place medec
mottaki et rostov à regarder
finir en s'ajustant à l'écouté de ce
disque winning mois au début avait rien
d'autre
j'ai commencé ce avant le thé où toutes
les autres sont arrivés après le thème
beaucoup mieux qu'ils étaient beaucoup
moins gras fait parce que les gens ont
réalisé que tu soleil était là le
premier mais c'était vraiment quelque
chose qui est fait c'est énormément là
après moi je moi c'est juste la
rattraper du temps c'est ce c'est le
seul que j'avais vu je connaissais pas
d'autres puits ne jamais parler de la
narration française jeudi
en fait je vous en français tuaient des
gens se soient que je tenais des dvd
j'adore encore listé c'est pour vraiment
partir de mouvements le port quand les
gens commencent à s'éduquer là dessus ça
va marcher
je pense qu'au niveau de l'environnement
il ya 86 kg p cette fête avec m
sinon tu dis que s'est occupé de
beaucoup beaucoup de pain sur la planche
aux rays en trop après ce nouveau
magasin des collectionneurs de sport de
coeur de ces quarts de sport restaurant
aura qui relie leggings notamment à base
de plastique recyclé radio la radio by
jean louis mercier
l'énergie est ce que j'en manque pitch
conférence est un deuxième groupe de
compagnies ça bien d'attendre que j'ai
fait que je peux pas encore dit mais ça
va 100 ça bientôt mais il y avait quand
on s'était parlé la première fois et
avait tu lances une décharge épicerie je
peux trouver quelque chose d'autre des
poussées finalement je ferais je fais
plus haut parce qu'on oublie ça c'est le
problème c'est que les gens qui étaient
là d'un s'était pas 100% williams qui
avait plongé des jambes accès 100 % t/t
zéro déchet sur ses pilotes finalement
ils peuvent pour faire 100 % vegan parce
que ils disent que danser zéro déchet
100% poétique quote moi c'est ça que
j'ai dit mais je peux patiner
si jamais ce genre dos à une épicerie
qui est en avance avec un oubli
seulement mais ça ça marche plus ça
ferait un scandale comme les châteaux
l'halloween l'épicerie qu'il y avait il
y avait dix y avait déjà eu il y avait
du fromage c'est comme ça c'est le mar
exemple le c est incroyable
la fin d'album qui parce que hugh 82 ans
à peu près l'halloween à cuinchy nous
tue les enfants sont peu son peuvent
également comme chez moi puis ce que
j'ai fait puis on parle des enfants ils
parlent alwena sens et qu'ils entraient
dans mon coin
les tout cas ce qu ils achètent des
parts de chacun ouais le thé des bois
pour l'halloween j'ai jamais comme l
épouvante avec une tête de citrouille
puis j'ai mis les boîtes le monde les
joies les 1,8 à tout le monde ouais ils
allaient vegan police a commencé mon
appartement j'ai dit des enfants l'accès
le challenge paul n'ya rien loupé ça
fait une tonne et ça crée un débat le
débat était devenue énorme le chausseur
à la parole
manson legault qui a fait ling invitons
à lire sa typo parce que je connais
quand même pas mal le milieu c'est
déjanté
si on commence à les reconnaître ont
regardé ce que je me disais c'est
notamment pour beaucoup e
beaucoup de gens qui refusent d'être des
gadjos à cause de ça parce que les
titres de certaines personnes c'est
tellement négatif
et quand ils voient seulement des le
monde je reçois des messages montrent
ils disent on n'a pas de parade qui
maçons ont pratiquement pleine côte
sauvage et à la faible estime lui prédit
x factor il promet manger de la viande
pis des rallyes tocci le quai ce qui
arriverait au mouvement
nancy sera affecté moi je les ai appelés
je réponde à du monde pilotes et j'ai
les jambes a été charmant et abraham des
10 membres des black eyed peas
le ski m'a fait vraiment amener jeu
parce qu'à la fin je vous suis est la
raison pour laquelle si légères comme à
savoir que le message de producteurs de
lait qui le remercie d'avoir fait la fin
j'ai dit bon ok je m'excuse je répondis
soir ça me désole pour ce job fisc et
puisque l'année d'après qui est cette
année j'ai acheté des trois heures je
regarde ma 3e cv gan ge est la même pour
tous avec des trois le bleu je recevais
des messages monde y compris pour
l'halloween qu'est ce qui va arriver
qu'est ce qu'il va faire le plein on se
demandait tout que ce que j'allais
attaquer le l'arrivée plus le monde
dirait que moi y'en a marre des messages
pour voir même photo de ce que tu vas
faire un cinoche s'était fait un genre
de guerrero et de twizz lake louise leur
infinie pour l'halloween cg comme j'ai
acheté comme car en boîte et je veux
toujours être ce qui agace passé dumas
restait comme comme 45 cd grosse car je
sais ce qu'il en reste encore et je suis
dit tiens ça me fait penser quand même
jean-philippe certains à tout le monde
en parle il y avait 10
si dans le temps des fêtes à grand mère
a fait des biscuits son podium je peux
quand même en manger puis à trois il ya
eu dix autres avoir une des meilleures
entrevues de tout le monde en parle il y
avait été exceptionnel c'est le pire est
que je montre qu'ils ont fait un éloge
en filet puis je dis que tu peux manger
là oui oui oui là le gars c'est un des
marins porte parole à bord et à des
recettes supérieures at il si peu
novateur puis tous se connaissent pas
bien pis comme tu le dis le voile
vigueur police qui arrive dans une dans
un monde tout seul puis qui capotent
sont énervés surtout eux sont négatifs
pour le maïs
ce que je trouve même si pippo
probablement puisque j'en parle avec ma
blonde dernièrement
probablement que ça vient vraiment potes
je mauvaise place c'est probablement que
c'est qu'ils ont comme une a1 a cumulé
envers la société dans laquelle on vit
qu'elle est c'est comme canalise mal
probablement leur message et c'est
sûrement pas d'une mauvaise place d'où
ça vient mais je pense pas que c'est
pour annoncer son nom devoir s'atteler
carnivores yade or ce titre oui mais oui
du monde vegan sinon ça n'a pas de sens
on est tellement peu on devrait bien
plus est uni position qui sauve le plus
d'animaux en bout de ligne c'est son
tour jean philippe
de toute façon c'est en bout de ligne
moi je regarde pas vraiment le le nom ou
la quantité regarde juste chaque
militant est important à 100 à 110 si la
personne est végétarienne elle et ellen
aidera courage déjà on peut manger
devient cellule arrière du car et elle
est vive entre ces hausses courage et
arrêtent un boisement paysage est la
même dans la même chose qui est la
personne à me manquer l'événement
effectif je te dis que mandé il ya des
gens qui commencent par sas est motivée
ça encourage les boîtiers comme moi si
je pars je prends ma guitare et je sais
je te dise est pour
début son cheminement merci maman jeu
mais en même temps je mets en garde
parce que souvent ce qui arrive c'est
que la végétarienne sont pas ensemble ou
si en santé parce qu'ils compensent
beaucoup avec les produits laitiers dont
le fromage pour des protéines parce que
ils peuvent en manger ce qui arrive
c'est que si tu manges reproduit le type
compenser le fait que tout est
végétarien empire de deux heures puis de
ceux là pour ta santé ça prenne
parce que j'étais son pays que la vie
affective tu mets des mises en garde
comme ça que le monde sont végétariens
et dispo je savais pas là au lieu de 100
à pitre et fromages à tous les jours ça
je mange pas de viande au moins dix
pensent manger du fromage un bloc équipe
de de matt garza tous les jours c'est le
contenu qui vont prendre les réalise que
là c'est moi avec le tranquille membres
30e ou du aussi absolument ils aiment le
fromage dès maintenant des bons fromages
reagan qui disent que tu peux remplacer
ce faire des affaires at il annoncé que
la merci la mise en garde mais et c'est
ce que je pense que dans tous les cas
c'est de manger diversifié aussi pitié
des phares mais les gens qui mangent de
la viande steak de patates avec trois
quartiers afin de reposer quand je
mangeais pro les deux colis l'autre jour
l'autre jour j'ai lu j'ai une
statistique puis au dessus de 20 mille
espèces de végétaux comestibles avec
20000 énorme qui s'était comme 90% ou
autour de 90 % de tout ce qu'on consomme
et dans 27 légumes
sur 20 me et 90% ce qu'on consomme ces
27 du vin émules
c'est fou pas rien
mais moi depuis depuis je suivais gamme
je mange des légumes que j'avais jamais
mangé avant constamment diabète dont
aller dans une friterie phare genre
c'est quoi c'est vraiment que je peux le
faire aussi être que tu échanger vos
félicitations à toi parce que c'est avec
l'émission vous avez fait il le fait
dans une émission qui change d'état par
le super important c'est pour la cause
parce que vous cherchez une honte
c est notre et non clients tels d'autres
personnes qui vont suivre qui va pas
monsieur le dessert marie complètement
parano branding qui chaque personne un
créneau de personnes qu'ils allaient
voir la végétaline qu'ils annoncent dans
la société c'est super important pour
mercier faut remercier ma blonde pour
ceux qui qualifient qu'elles aient les
bons arguments pareils tête over
d'espoir at a rapidement faute quand
beaucoup de personnalité les pires du
move et rentrent c'est quand même il
faut il faut reconnaître que tous les
gens savent où tu parle à quelqu'un y
réussit h qui t'écoutent vie qui change
parce que la personne des querelles et
tout va bien est sensible à toutes les
causes comparable ça commence comme ça
fait cui a été bonne a tant parlé mais
quand même toit le faisait avec cette
tenue à la norme jusqu'à 2,7 à réaliser
moi j'ai dit c'est avec mon mode de vie
carnivores puis ma vie ou ce que je
serais aujourd'hui j'ai pas besoin de la
paix n'était pas obligé de changer comme
ça puis de l'avoir de l'avoir gardé
aussi créatrice beaucoup et on va cela
c'est sûr ça sur ces belles paroles
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là d'avoir
pris tant pour fournir ici nous
rejoindre cela sont des techs non avec
les gens allaient devoir tomber stopin
blog est un peu de tes enfants ou même
site quoi pas besoin vraiment hip hop
juste m'écrire dans mons est gentiment
jacqueline comme les accords des
questions comme est que là dessus mais
moi je la conseille j'ai aimé soya merci
merci merci
la caisse
[Musique]